Exzellent.
Ja, Patrick, ich hätte das gemacht.
Ich hätte jetzt live im Stream
Streamprofile signiert, hättest du nicht den Channel gelöscht.
Was macht ihr eigentlich alle schon hier?
Habt ihr alle nichts zu tun?
Instant die Leute am Start.
Ja, schneller als gestern Abend.
Vor gestern Abend.
Oder wann auch immer ich zuletzt on war.
Gestern Morgen. Null W.
Pause Champ.
Homeoffice. Beste.
Ja, muss ich morgen auch wieder.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie lange ich...
Ach, guck mal, der Wettbewerb ist jetzt auch am Start.
Und schon was von Logitech gehört.
Bin ja gespannt,
was da rauskommt.
Wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich genau on bin.
Ich will ein bisschen rumbasteln.
Also, die Sache ist,
ich hab grad übelst
Pepo Happy Fat gemacht.
Ich hab wieder...
Ich hab euch doch letztens gezeigt,
ich hab mir doch so ein Nudel- und Soßen-
Probierpaket bestellt aus Italien.
Ich hab heute Rigatoni...
Oder, oder, wie spricht man das überhaupt richtig aus?
Nicht Rigatoni...
Rigatoni. Keine Ahnung.
Und mit Tomatensauce aus dem Glas,
was ich da bestellt hab.
Ist zwar nicht billig,
aber schmeckt echt...
Eis.
Und ich bin jetzt so vollgefressen,
dass ich jetzt die Auswahl hab.
Entweder ich setz mich jetzt vor den Rechner
und penn wahrscheinlich ein dabei,
weil ich so vollgefressen bin.
Oder ich mach einfach Stream an.
Excellent. Wopok.
Ich mach jetzt einfach Stream an,
dann muss ich ein bisschen schwätzen
und kann nicht einpennen.
Das heißt, mal gucken...
Mal gucken, wie lang ich's durchhalte.
Und ich hab gedacht,
wir können eine Sache machen,
die ich mir schon eine Weile angucken wollte,
nämlich Tailwind CSS.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin kein krasser Design-Sorber,
was Frontend angeht.
Ich muss erst mal nicht vm anmachen
und ich hab irgendwas im Auge.
Äh.
Genau.
Und zwar...
Alter, ey, was hab ich denn im Auge hängen?
Das sackt ja mal richtig, Alter.
So.
Äh, und zwar...
Ich bin ja nicht der tolle, äh, Design-Mensch,
was Frontend angeht.
Ich hab das bisher zum größten Teil
eigentlich immer hier mitgemacht.
Huch.
Also, bisher verwende ich fürs Frontend...
Ja, Nudeln.
Genau.
Äh.
Was ist das für ein Kokona-Hintergrund, Alter?
Massive Kokona-Style.
Was ist das für ein Bing?
Das ist Bing Image of the Day.
Hell yeah.
Wo ist die M16, äh?
By the way,
der einzige Service, wofür ich Bing verwende,
Image of the Day, äh.
So.
Bisher mach ich mein Frontend-Kram ja hauptsächlich damit,
weil ich ein Kack-Nude bin
und von Design-Kramern
keine Ahnung habe.
Deswegen mach ich das immer damit,
weil das ist easy as fuck, ja.
Ähm.
Da ist das mehr oder weniger alles schon fertig.
Wenn ich so ne Karte machen will,
dann mach ich hier Kart
und mach drei Buttons rein
und dann sieht das so aus.
So.
Das mach ich bisher damit,
aber
der neueste Shit ist jetzt...
Ja, was heißt der neueste?
So neu ist das gar nicht.
Aber voll angesagt ist jetzt das hier aktuell.
Hier.
Tailwind CSS.
Und...
Im Prinzip muss man da die Sachen,
also wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab,
da macht man damit das Design nach wie vor komplett selbst,
aber...
Es ist wohl einfacher
und schneller zu, zu, äh...
Wie sagt man so schön?
Prototypen
als
direkt CSS zu programmieren.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ich bin schlechter Frontend-Designer, was das angeht.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich probier das mal aus.
Ich wollte schon ne ganze Weile ausprobieren,
und dann hab ich mir gedacht, komm, warum machen wir das nicht jetzt einfach mal im Stream?
Ja.
Aber wenn man sich die Tailwind-Homepage anguckt, ne?
Dann...
Dann sind nur Mädels am Tailwind programmieren.
Guck hier.
Hier oben.
Da.
Da fühl ich mich ja nicht included, äh.
Gleich...
Deinstallieren.
Genau.
Frontend-Grills.
Hahaha.
Das stimmt aber tatsächlich.
Ist aber echt so.
Also...
Wenn ich, wenn ich mal bei uns auf der Arbeit gucke, wie sich das verteilt...
So, äh...
Also, wie...
Ich nehm jetzt mal nur IT-Sachen, ja?
In der Personalabteilung sind zu 90% Mädels.
Das lass ich jetzt mal außen vor.
Wenn ich aber mal bei uns auf der Arbeit gucke...
Also, im Admin-Bereich haben wir...
Genau...
Eine.
Und die macht Datenbank-Zeug.
So.
Das sind quasi 99% Männer.
Ähm...
Dann...
Im Software-Entwicklungsbereich...
Da weiß ich, dass wir...
Also, ist ja viel Java...
Java-Backend-Gedöns und sowas.
Da weiß ich zumindest, dass wir noch zwei Stück haben.
Aber von insgesamt fragt mich nicht.
Massig, massig Kerlen.
Das sind auch 95% Männer.
Aber es gibt zwei Bereiche, da muss man sagen, da haben wir auch tatsächlich relativ viele...
Wo ist die Leise?
Relativ viele Mädels.
Und...
Alter, der Chat, der will wieder alles falsch verstehen.
Und zwar, wir haben im Frontend-Bereich und in iOS-Apps haben wir relativ viele.
Also, iOS besteht bei uns gefühlt zu 50-50 aus Mädels und Kerlen.
Und, ähm...
So Frontend-Design-Gedöns würde ich auch mal sagen 50-50.
Also, es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so weit hergeholt.
Im Frontend-Bereich gibt es tatsächlich ganz viele Mädels, ja.
Wobei, bei uns Frontend...
Wisst ihr, was bei uns Frontend bedeutet zum größten Teil?
Ratet mal, was heißt bei uns Frontend?
Okay, der Chat hat keine Ahnung.
Naja, ich würde mal sagen, ein ganz großer Teil ist Wordpress immer noch.
Das war klar.
Wordpress.
Nein, aber nicht nur.
Aber es ist viel Wordpress.
Also, die ganzen Blogs und...
Ja, was wir da so alles haben, ist zum größten Teil Wordpress.
Und die Sache ist halt die...
Diese Wordpress-Dinger, die sind ja irgendwie auch...
Nein, nicht unkaputtbar ist das falsche Wort.
Die sind hartnäckig, ja.
Die Website ist...
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube, das ist kein Wordpress.
Die Homepage...
Achso!
Ne, das ist kein Wordpress.
Das ist irgendwas, was irgendein polnischer Anbieter programmiert hat für uns.
Das...
Hahaha.
Und das Geile ist...
Und das Geile ist, die haben mittlerweile total viel Zeug so outsourced.
Ich mache mal übrigens gerade nebenbei Betriebssystem-Update, ja.
Die haben total viel Zeug outgesourced, dass das jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr...
Was ist denn mit der Musik los?
Die kann ja mal einheitlich laut sein.
Dass das überhaupt nicht mehr richtig zusammenpasst, ja.
Du hast dann...
Du hast irgendwelche Wordpress-Geschichten da.
Dann hast du irgendwelche Custom-CMS-Sachen da.
Dann hast du irgendwie Java und...
Bei dem anderen ist sogar noch ein Angular-Frontend und das andere.
Also, das ist total wirr.
Es passt überhaupt nichts zusammen.
Und dementsprechend freuen sich, glaube ich, nur die Stonks-Männer aktuell, dass das so geil Cloud ist alles.
Too much information.
Ihr habt eh nichts davon, wenn ihr es wisst.
Ne, aber das ist witzig.
Das ganze Outgesource...
Das geht immer nur vordergründig gut.
Patrick, ich habe das ernsthaft mal in einem Stream geleakt.
Wirklich?
Schreibt mir mal, please, im Discord, was ich da geleakt habe im Stream.
Kann ich mich gar nicht dran erinnern.
Habe ich nicht versprochen oder so?
Naja, egal.
Okay, habe ich Updates durch hier?
Excellent, excellent, alles klar.
Habe ich ein Betriebssystem-Update gemacht?
Ja, sehr gut.
Okay, ich reboote nochmal.
Ich weiß ja...
Oh, fuck.
Ich kack nur.
Ich wollte mal gucken, ob es neue Kernel gibt.
Trunk-Stream.
Ja, so Ultra-Trunk-Stream habe ich ja noch nie gehabt.
Ich war am Silvester mal ein bisschen besoffen, aber das war es eigentlich.
So.
Aber gibt es hier neue Körner?
Zeige ich mal da.
Running.
Nope.
Wir haben das Alleraktuellste.
Poggers.
Massive Poggers.
Oh, ne, Leute.
Wisst ihr was?
Oh, ganz jetzt wird es ätzend.
Ich muss JavaScript-Zeug aktualisieren.
Wie macht man das überhaupt?
Update?
So?
Ne.
Ähm.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht.
Jetzt müssen wir das halbe Internet downloaden.
Okay.
Das ist Manjaro, ja.
Kann ich sowas hier machen?
Global Update?
Ne.
Äh.
Upgrade.
Okay.
Upgrade ist es.
Alles klar.
So.
Internet Download läuft.
Das ist ein LTS-Körnel.
Ja, aber das ist doch trotzdem der Aktuellste gerade, oder?
War das nicht gerade...
Ist das nicht gerade erst rausgekommen?
Das ist doch der Letzte.
Das ist auch ein L...
Ne.
Ist das ein 510er LTS?
Stimmt.
Doch.
Das müsste eigentlich ein LTS sein.
Ist das ein LTS?
Ja, das ist ein LTS.
Nice.
Okay.
Na, dann kann ich den auch eine Weile behalten.
So.
Hat er jetzt...
Hat er jetzt geupdatet?
Okay.
Internet-Zeug ist aktualis...
Äh.
JavaScript-Zeug ist aktualisiert.
Sehr gut.
Manjaro, das Betriebssystem, wo noch Devs wie Nutzer bei Bugs haben können...
Ist das so?
Ich verfolge das überhaupt nicht.
Ich benutze den Kram nur und wenn die sich da irgendwo anders auskotzen wollen...
Kein Schimmer.
Ja, das ist auch geil, ne?
Ja, ja.
Das ist bei diesem JavaScript-Zeug übrigens normal.
Wenn du irgendwas installierst und irgendwas machst, du kriegst erstmal 20 Millionen Warnings
und kannst im Endeffekt nichts dagegen machen.
Okay.
Getting...
Getting started.
Ich hab...
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung davon.
Ach so.
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal gucken, ob es irgendwelche Visual Studio Add-Ons gibt.
Für diesen Kram.
Was haben wir...
Was haben wir denn hier eigentlich alles rumliegen, Alter?
Wie viele Temp-Ordner habe ich jetzt schon?
Temp, Temp 2, Temp 0.
Okay.
Ja, dann fehlt jetzt ja eindeutig noch Temp-Keg W.
Temp-Keg W fehlt noch.
So ist das gut.
Da machen wir das jetzt drin.
Wunderbar.
Temp, Temp.
Auf der Arbeit ist ganz...
Ganz...
Ganz schrecklich, ne?
Ja.
Das ist nicht auf, das macht nichts.
Hab ich euch mal erzählt, dass ich, dass sie sich auf der Arbeit einmal beschwert haben, dass ich indirekt zu Hackerman bin.
Und zwar, ich hab auf nem internen Fileserver, den es gibt für PowerPoint-Vorlagen und solche Dinger, hab ich mein Linux-Backup drauf gemacht.
Und es war dann halt irgendwie, frag mich nicht, 200G oder so, ich hab einfach die ganze Festplatte, die ganze SSD inklusive 4M-Images und alles drauf, drauf Backup, mit Borg-Backup.
Und irgendwann war ich dann auf diesem Fileserver, derjenige dann irgendwie über die Hälfte an Speicherplatz verwendet hat.
Ey, ich mein, irgendwohin muss ich Backups machen, ja?
Und es ist dann irgendwann aufgefallen, dass das irgendwie keine PowerPoint-Vorlagen...
... mit Folien sind und sonstige Dinger.
Nutzt du bei der Arbeit nur Linux oder wirst du gezwungen, auch Windows laufen zu haben?
Oh, das ist ein schönes Thema.
Also, aktuell hab ich's auf der Arbeit so, ich hab ne Linux-Notebook und zwei Windows-VMs.
Das ist das Wollen, das ist irgendwie ne neue Policy.
Es gibt eine VM mit vielen Freischaltungen für Admins und eine normale Arbeits-Windows-VM.
So, und dann hab ich halt mein Notebook noch am Start.
So, wunderbar.
Ist eigentlich auch ganz cool.
Auch mit Manjaro, mit der gleichen Config, hier, mit hier, mit der gleichen Config drauf.
So, und jetzt ist es so, irgendjemand ist auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen, dass...
Ich hab euch ja erzählt, wir hatten letztes Mal Probleme mit so nem Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner.
Oder was Trojaner?
So ein Verschlüsselungs-Ding, was dann angefangen hat, Windows-Fileserver zu verschlüsseln und sowas.
Was witzig ist, dass keines der Linux-Systeme...
betroffen war, aber gut, aber gut.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt überall Windows Defender.
Er gibt auch...
Habt ihr schon mal Windows Defender unter Linux betrieben?
Ich weiß jetzt, wie geil das ist.
Ja?
Wir haben jetzt auf der Arbeit, nämlich per Policy, auf fast allen Linux-Kisten haben wir Windows Defender drauf.
Ist jetzt kein Witz, ist jetzt kein Witz.
Das gibt's, jaja.
Das heißt, ähm, Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection oder so.
Äh, ATP, Microsoft...
Advanced Threat Protection.
Das gibt's auch für Linux.
Das ist Advanced, ja?
Microsoft Defender, ADP für...
Ja, den Crap...
haben wir da jetzt laufen.
Und das Ding macht nur Probleme, ne?
Wir haben, wir haben Mail-Server und sonstige Dinge, die haben jetzt 50% CPU-Auslastung.
Nur mit, äh, nur wegen dem, nur wegen dem Microsoft Antivirus.
Und das Geile ist, es ist dann letztens rausgekommen, der Microsoft Antivirus ist sogar nur im Lock-Only-Modus, nicht im Scan-und-Mach-Modus.
Was im Prinzip bedeutet, wenn man das Ding richtig einschalten würde...
Wie viel, wie viel... macht das dann 80% CPU-Last?
Oder was?
Das ist wirklich Ultra-Crap Advanced CPU Usage.
Ah, ACU ist das dann.
So.
Genau.
Und...
Um mal wieder auf diese, auf diese Frage zurückzukommen.
Also, und dann haben sie sich jetzt überlegt, es ist jetzt Pflicht für alle bei uns auf der Arbeit, kommt jetzt demnächst, dass man Windows verwendet.
Also sprich, auf den Notebooks.
Also im Prinzip, ich mach dann mein Linux halt auf eine VM drauf.
Ist eigentlich im Prinzip auch kein Problem.
Aktuell arbeite ich eh nur Remote PSSH.
Das juckt mich jetzt nicht, nicht großartig.
Aber ich bin dann schon mal gespannt, wie viel länger manche Sachen dauern.
Weil Copy und Paste nicht richtig funktioniert.
Zwischen Windows und Linux.
Wenn ich manche Sachen nicht mehr nachinstallieren kann.
Wenn ich nicht einfach mal einen TCP-Dump machen kann.
Oder irgendwas.
Da bin ich schon mal gespannt drauf.
Wie viel, wie oft dann Leute keck-waiten, weil ich ihnen sagen muss, funktioniert halt nicht richtig.
Ja, also, ja, WSL...
Nee, WSL 2 ist nicht möglich.
WSL 1.
Für WSL 2 ist unsere, ist unsere Windows zu alt.
Aber es ist letztendlich wurscht.
WSL geht.
Ähm, WSL ist halbwegs erträglich, ja.
Also, WSL ist okay.
Was mir halt ein bisschen fehlt, ist, dass man grafische Programme gescheit verwenden kann.
Aber da gibt's ja mittlerweile Möglichkeiten, die allerdings tatsächlich nicht so gut funktionieren.
Wirklich, wie mit einem richtigen, echten X-Rover unter Linux.
Mal gucken.
Es wird bestimmt, es wird bestimmt witzig.
Aber mittlerweile mach ich mir da gar keine Gedanken mehr drüber.
Weil, letztendlich bezahlen die mich dann fürs Nichts machen.
Also, wenn's halt nicht geht, dann, dann, bläh, kann ja auch nix für.
Äh, dankeschön, Sarix, für den 2 Monate Sub.
Sorry, falls ich irgendwelche Subs vergessen hab.
Ich glaub, ich scroll mal kurz ganz schnell drüber.
Ich glaube nicht.
Nee, nicht.
SF-Subscriptions hier.
Was die wollen bei uns danach...
Was die wollen bei uns...
Ein Panda-Antivirus.
Was zum...
So viel Crap.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Warum die so scharf drauf sind, sich Müll zu installieren.
Äh, hey Max, bin gestern wieder in China gekommen.
Kommt da eigentlich nochmal?
Ähm, ich hab in letzter Zeit nicht so viel Interessantes da, was ich zeigen könnte, gekauft.
Und das Video hat jetzt auch nicht so viele Leute interessiert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da nochmal eins mache.
Advanced Agile Antivirus.
Ja.
Oh, das ist eklig.
Also, man muss sagen, wirklich gute Open Source Antivirus gibt's nicht.
Aber man kann sich generell darüber streiten, ob es überhaupt guten Antivirus gibt.
Aber wie gesagt, es gibt Microsoft Defender oder Microsoft Defender auch für Linux, ja.
Wahrscheinlich auch für Mac.
Wann kommt Schneestells?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht lade ich den Schneestells sogar als nächstes hoch, weil ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, was ich als richtig echtes Video aufnehmen sollte.
Kann ich einfach am Mittwoch oder so den Schneestells hochladen und hab dann wieder 4 Tage Luft, wo ich mir was überlegen kann.
Ich hab mir ja so überlegt, dass ich alle 4-5 Tage was hochlade.
Kommt ja eigentlich auch ganz gut hin.
Und Schneestells, wenn jetzt der Schnee überall wieder weg ist, ist eigentlich besonders gut.
Okay, also, wie benutzt man den Kram jetzt?
Wir haben einen neuen Ordner, excellent.
Keck Wait.
Wir haben bei uns auf der Arbeit unter Windows haben wir Kaspersky am Start, glaube.
Und das ist auch geil.
Da sind die Commodots immer direkt am Start, ja.
Das hat dieses Verschlüsselungsding nicht erkannt, ne.
Und jetzt haben sie Kaspersky und Windows Defender zusammen am Start, glaube ich.
Auf den Windows Sachen.
Das kommt sich wahrscheinlich dann auch noch in die Quere.
Okay, also, fangen wir mal an.
Ich wollte mir Vue.js angucken.
Als erstes, also Betriebssystem geupdatet.
Habe ich schon, wunderbar.
Ich wollte mal schnell gucken, ob es Visual Studio Code Extensions für gibt.
Aber vorher müssen wir ein Projekt anlegen.
Also, Integration Guides.
Ich würde ja gerne ein Vue.js Projekt nehmen.
Aber anscheinend geht das nicht.
Doch, Vue 3 kann man nehmen.
Alles klar.
Okay, wie fandest du das? Zeig mal her.
Aha, NPM.
Jan ist out, ne.
Leute, JavaScript entwickelt sich so schnell, da blickst du nicht mal durch.
Also, es gibt ja als Paketmanager hast du Jan und NPM für Node.
Und vor zwei Jahren war NPM übelst verpönt bei manchen.
Und da war Jan voll angesagt.
Und jetzt ist Jan nicht mehr angesagt und NPM wieder voll in.
Ist Deno eigentlich schon wieder tot?
Ne, oder?
Deno ist voll, voll, geht immer noch gut ab.
Ja, ist nicht tot.
Jan hat es verkackt mit Jan 2.
Weil Jan 2 nicht mehr, nicht mehr kompatibel zu Jan 1 ist.
Total, total verschissen, ja.
Und bei Deno bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob das weite Verbreitung finden wird.
Also, im Prinzip ist Deno quasi...
Ne Node mit eingebautem TypeScript Support und noch ein bisschen mehr.
Nur, dass es kein Node ist, sondern Rust und V8 Bindings und frag mir nicht.
Ist J nicht auch inzwischen unmaintained?
Ernsthaft?
Wollen die mich veräppeln?
Ich habe erst den Joghurt verwendet, der war unmaintained.
Dann habe ich Tritzen verwendet, das war Perl und hat gesackt.
Dann habe ich J verwendet und jetzt ist das auch unmaintained?
Wirklich?
Ne.
Vor 16...
J beendet mich nicht.
Vor 16 Stunden wurde da zuletzt was Dings, das ist nicht unmaintained.
Passt.
Alles gut.
Ist das so?
Eben haben meine Shit Packages Updates bekommen.
Shit.
Meine Shit Packages.
So.
Ja.
Und wo ich mich frage bei Deno, ob das nennenswerte Verbreitung finden wird.
Nennenswerte Verbreitung findet ist...
Eines der größten Vorteile von Node ist ja gerade, dass es so viele Packages gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die hier irgendwelche Statistiken haben, wie viele Packages das da insgesamt am
Start sind.
Weiß nicht, haben die Stats oder so?
Keine Ahnung, ob man sieht, wie viele Packages da insgesamt...
Ich weiß nicht.
Es gibt Milliarden NPN Packages gefühlt.
Und Deno kann die halt nicht verwenden.
Deswegen frage ich mich halt, wie gut das sich verbreitet.
Man kann jetzt von Node halten, was man will, aber das NPN Ökosystem ist schon ganz nice.
Auch wenn ich mich immer gern drüber lustig mache, dass wenn du ein Update machst, der
alles nachinstalliert.
Das halbe Internet, aber...
Max, erzähl mal bitte Geschichte zum Shit Repo.
Habe ich doch schon total oft.
Soll ich...
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich was machen.
Okay, ich erzähle euch ganz kurz die Geschichte zum Shit Repo.
Aber nur in zwei Minuten.
Und zwar, wir hatten mal einen Azubi bei uns.
Und der hatte nicht so den allergrößten Durchblick.
Ich glaube, da war in dem Beruf nicht richtig.
Und der ist jetzt auch Junior Consultant irgendwo.
Also Junior Consultant ist so das Auffangbecken für alle, die nichts können.
Naja, zumindest...
Der konnte, der konnte durchaus was, aber halt nichts technisches.
Ich glaube, verkaufen kann der Typ echt nicht schlecht.
So, und...
Der war bei uns mal zwei, drei Monate am Start.
Und wir hatten damals jemand bei uns im Team, der hat die Sachen alle so super geil ausgesprochen.
Der hat dann gesagt, Jyra...
Wobei Jyra ja so halbwegs noch stimmt.
Äh...
Shit.
Und...
Jubantu.
Und was auch immer.
Der hat alles super geil ausgesprochen.
Und der Azubi hat das halt sich angehört und gedacht, so spricht man die Sachen aus.
Das Problem ist nur, dass man halt Git nicht Shit ausspricht.
Und der Azubi hat es halt dann auch noch ein bisschen falsch ausgesprochen.
Und bei uns ist das so, dass die Azubis nach irgendwie, frag mich nicht einmal im halben Jahr oder so,
müssen immer eine Präsentation halten über das, was sie in dem letzten halben Jahr gemacht haben.
Und dann stand der halt oben, wo Leute auch vom Vorstand dabei waren.
Das ist bei uns übelste, übelste Ansage.
Das ist eine Anzugträger-Veranstaltung.
Das ist so, so Prestige-Ding immer.
Und also da sind immer die, die, die ganzen Oberstocks-Leute dabei.
Und die Azubis scheißen sich immer halb in die Hose, wenn sie da hinmüssten.
Naja.
Zumindest...
Doch, das spricht, das spricht man so aus, ja.
Zumindest war der dann halt dort am Start und hat dann, hat dann seine Vorstellung
gemacht und hat dann halt vor diesen Leuten gestanden, die halt, muss man halt dazu sagen,
die haben technisch absolut gar keinen Plan, die Leute, die da sitzen.
Ja, null.
Bis auf zwei, drei Leute, die halt dabei eingeladen wurden und halt zufällig mal dabei sind.
Und er hat dann halt oben vor diesen ganzen Anzugleuten gestanden und hat gesagt, er hat
Sachen eingecheckt in das Shit-Repo.
Und die haben sich halt total entgeistert und empört schon angeguckt.
Was ist mit dem los?
Will der jetzt besonders cool klingen oder was?
Was ist hier los?
Was soll, was soll das hier bedeuten?
Shit.
Sowas geht hier...
Die, die waren schon quasi kurz vor der Abmahnung im Endeffekt.
Und...
Bis ihn dann einer gerettet hat.
Eine, eine.
Bis ihn dann eine gerettet hat und meinte halt, ach hier, du meinst unser Git-Repo.
Und dann meinte er so, ja, ja, hab ich doch gesagt.
Er meinte halt, er hat ein, wisst ihr, das, die, die haben gedacht, er macht jetzt so
den geilen Freestyle-Rap.
Ich hab's eingecheckt in das Shit-Repo.
Und das meinte er halt nicht.
Und das ist bei uns mittlerweile so der Running Gag.
Das, wir sagen ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr, keiner, keiner bei uns auf der Arbeit,
mit denen ich öfters was, was da zu tun hab, auch Git-mäßig sagt noch Git.
Wir sagen alle Shit.
Wir sagen alle was, so an Anlehnung an diese Geschichte, Shit.
Auch wenn's, wenn wir jeder wissen, das spricht man nicht so aus, ja.
Shit.
So.
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ähm.
Ich soll, ich soll, ich sollte irgendwas installieren, steht da.
Also.
Ah.
Wo auf Vue.
Vue 3, dann machen wir das mit Vue 3.
Da war das der Celatenzaun-Typ, korrekt.
Ja.
Laut, laut dem gleichen Azubi heißt C-Sharp auch Celatenzaun.
Gif weiß ich nicht, Gif.
Wobei Gif ist bestimmt ein Jif bei dem, auch Jif, Alter.
Genau, bei dem war das auch Celatenzaun.
Nein, der hat nicht getrollt.
Der wusste das einfach nicht.
Na komm, C-Rauter hat doch jeder auch schon mal irgendwo gehört.
Der hat nicht getrollt, der wusste es einfach nicht.
Ob das das ist?
Nein, mittlerweile weiß er es.
Und das Witzige war, ich habe den ja sogar mal was in C-Lattenzaun programmieren lassen.
Und zwar so einen BMI-Rechner.
Also BMI-Rechner, dass man erkennt, ob man richtig schön pepo-fett ist.
Nee, einfach nur, weil es eine easy Übung ist.
Und BMI-Rechner, so nach dem Motto, geben sie ihre Größe ein, geben sie ihr Gewicht ein und sowas.
Dann rechnet er das aus.
Und das war halt auch der gleiche Azubi, der dann irgendwann, frag mich nicht,
der hat zwei Tage oder so rumgemacht an so einem BMI-Rechner.
Das sind fünf Zeilen Code oder so.
Da kann nicht allzu viel passieren, normalerweise allzu viel schief gehen.
Zwei Tage hat er da rumgewurstelt und hat es nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Irgendwann kommt er dann zu mir und meint so, Max, es funktioniert, es funktioniert.
Da habe ich gesagt, ja, zeig mal her.
Und im Endeffekt, was er gemeint hat halt, ja, okay, es hat zum ersten Mal richtig kompiliert.
Er hat keinen Fehler gekriegt bei mir fünf drücken.
So, und dann hat er so ein Programm gehabt, da stand dann sowas da wie, ähm, äh, keine Ahnung, geben sie,
geben sie ihr Gewicht in Kilogramm ein.
So, sowas hatte der dann.
Und dann habe ich dann, dann habe ich dann einfach mal eingegeben, hallo.
Und dann ist das Programm gecrashed.
Und dann hat er gemeint, nein, das darfst du doch nicht eingeben.
Du musst da Zahlen eingeben.
Und ich sagte, ja, wo hast du, wo soll ich das wissen?
Und dann war er wieder ganz aufgelöst, ey.
Oh Mann.
Ja, das war schon witzig.
Der war nicht blöd.
Der war, der war auf seine Art sogar relativ, äh, pfeifert.
Also der, der hatte echt Talent dafür.
Das habe ich so auch selten erlebt.
Und zwar, der konnte on the fly wechseln von, er hat Ahnung zu, er hat keine Ahnung.
Äh, Pris, Pris, er rief, danke schön für den Prime Sub.
Also sprich, normalerweise merkst du das.
Wenn, wenn, mal angenommen, ihr habt irgendwelche, ähm, Verkaufsleute da, die euch jetzt irgendwie ein neues Ticketsystem anpreisen wollen, so.
Und die erzählen dann, die erzählen dann, und du fragst die was, die erzählen, erzählen.
Und meistens merkst du relativ, relativ genau, wenn die Leute anfangen, keine Ahnung mehr zu haben.
Das hört man eigentlich ganz gut raus.
Von, von, sie wissen, wovon sie reden, zu, sie sagen einfach nur irgendwas, das es einem gefällt.
Das, das merkt, das hörst du eigentlich relativ schnell raus.
Und der hatte echten Talent dafür, diesen Übergang möglichst fließend zu gestalten.
Also sprich, der konnte dir was erzählen, und dann konnte der genauso, gleiche Tonlage, gleiche Aussagekraft, so, gleich, gleiche Aussprache, konnte der weiterreden.
Und er wusste nicht mehr, wovon er redet.
Also eigentlich, das wird, das ist bestimmt ein super Junior, Junior Consultant, Verkäufer, der Typ mittlerweile.
Problem ist nur, wenn auf der anderen Seite jemand sitzt, der halt weiß,
was er erzählt.
Und, äh, Fips, ja genau, das ist der, der halben Nervenzusammenbruche wegen, wegen Netzwerkfragen von mir hatte, ja.
Der arme Kerl, ey, da, da, da hab ich heute echt immer noch ein bisschen schlechtes Gewissen.
Das, da hätte ich ehrlich gesagt, naja, eigentlich hätte ich da nicht mit rechnen können, ja.
Aber, äh, da hat er mir echt leid getan.
Ja, oh man, das war schon was.
Der Herr Endpunkt, der Herr Endpunkt B-Punkt.
Ich hoffe aber, dem geht's gut, und ich hoffe auch, der hat jetzt was ordentliches gefunden, was zu ihm passt.
Naja, wie dem auch sei.
Also, was soll ich denn machen, um Tailwind ausprobieren zu können?
Mit View 3 und White.
Was war denn nochmal White?
Ich kenn View CLI.
Was zum Geier ist White?
Warum, warum hast du, warum heißt es White?
Und nicht Black oder so?
Warum, warum White?
Das ist doch ganz verpönt heutzutage.
Oder wenigstens, Pride.
Sollte Pride heißen, nicht White.
Egal, ähm, genug dummes Zeug erzählt, was ist denn das?
WhiteJS, schau wieder was Neues, please!
Gibt es irgendwann mal eine Woche, wo keine neuen JavaScript-Frameworks entstehen?
Moment, das hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Da war das nicht dieser Bundler?
Von den ViewJS-Leuten?
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich mach einfach...
Ich weiß nicht genau, was da in dem Getting Started steht.
Ähm, aber mal ganz im Ernst, ich wollte eigentlich, eigentlich wollte ich ein ViewCLI-Projekt machen.
Egal, egal.
Das hast du letztens erst angeschaut.
Ja, genau, deswegen kam mir das auch bekannt vor.
Das ist dieser Bundler von den, von den ViewJS-Leuten.
Okay, wir machen jetzt einfach mal, so wie man das immer machen muss bei JavaScript, einfach random irgendwelche Befehle aus dem Internet ausführen.
Also, ähm, myProject.
Nein, das heißt, doch, doch, wir bleiben jetzt einfach mal bei dem Beispiel.
Äh, ViewLitElement, Alter.
Also, Vanilla kann ich mir vorstellen.
Vanilla ist JavaScript.
So, View, ViewTypeScript, React, ReactTypeScript.
Aber was zum Geil ist Preact?
Was zum...
JavaScript, Alter.
JavaScript.
Und was ist LitElement?
Doch, LitElement kenn ich.
LitElement, das kenn ich.
Das ist, äh, WebComponents.
Irgendein WebComponents-Helper-Framework oder so.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Okay, wir machen, wir stinken nochmal.
Kein Types, wir machen einfach ein stinknormales View3-Projekt.
Excellent.
Okay.
CD.
Wir brauchen Peter Agile.
Genau.
Das ist...
Preact rendert schon, bevor der User überhaupt auf die Webseite geht.
Ja, proaktiv hat man dazu früher gesagt.
Quasi...
Predicted Rendering oder so.
Das rendert einfach schon mal in der Hoffnung, der User geht in nächster Zeit drauf.
Eigentlich Big...
So was soll...
Eigentlich eine übelst geile Idee.
So was müssen wir erfinden, Leute.
AI-based Rendering.
Wir, wir predikten einfach, wann der User die Webseite besucht und dann rendern wir schon mal.
Und, und wir wissen das irgendwann besser als der User selbst, wann er auf die Webseite geht.
Okay.
Also, CD.
Ne, haben wir schon.
Also, npm install.
Excellent.
Alles klar.
Okay, halbes Internet.
Halbes Internet wird installiert.
Übrigens, das Geile ist wirklich, ne.
Jedes Mal, wenn du npm ausführst, bestehen erstmal zwölf Auswarnings.
Ja, und wenn man das Ganze noch rendern lässt in Stadia, hat man auch negative Latenz.
Genau.
Okay, was haben wir denn jetzt hier?
Tailwind.
Ja, ich hab aktuell das Note.
Install.
Tailwind mit npm.
Das installieren haben wir nicht nur Tailwind.
Das installiert Tailwind, PostCSS und den Autoprefixer.
Der Autoprefixer.
Der macht wahrscheinlich automatisch Prefixes.
Sowas wie "-webkit".
Oder sowas.
Vermute ich einfach mal.
Der Autoprefix.
Leute, danach machen wir mal, danach machen wir mal nen DU und gucken, wie groß das Projekt ist.
Wartet mal.
Ey, du.
Das, das ist aber nicht viel.
Semkado, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Nur 84 MB.
Das ist ja nix.
Also für, für JavaScript ist das ja.
Das ist, das ist ja quasi.
Hello World.
84 MB.
Jetzt, jetzt hör mal auf, also.
Da geht so ein ordentliches JavaScript-Projekt gar nicht mal los.
Mit 84 MB.
Lightweight.
Lightweight-JS, ja.
84 MB.
Normales, normales Projekt hat nach nem NPM-Install, das muss mindestens 2,5G haben.
Dass das überhaupt alles Wichtige dabei hat.
Okay, also.
Kennst du das Framework Vanilla-JS?
Wie, gibt's das ernsthaft?
Ich, ich, ich dachte immer mit Vanilla ist einfach schlicht und ergreifend gemeint.
Äh, JavaScript ohne irgendwelche Zusatzsachen.
Ach, das ist ein Witz.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja gut, wenigstens, wenigstens veräppeln sich die JavaScript-Leute mittlerweile selbst.
Okay, und jetzt machen wir NPX.
Den Unterschied zwischen NPM und NPX hab ich noch nicht kapiert.
Was?
NPM vs. NPX.
What's the difference?
Genau, erzähl mal.
NPM ist der Package-Manager und NPX.
What the?
Och ne, schon wieder dieser nervige Spam, alter.
So.
Klickt die Kack-Links nicht an.
Instant sperren.
NPM execute.
Ja, warum, warum kann man nicht einfach NPM run verwenden?
NPM run mit irgendeinem Script.
Warum braucht man dann extra Dings dafür?
Okay.
Wir hinterfragen das einfach nicht.
So ist es halt im JavaScript-Land.
Excellent.
Jetzt haben wir eine Tailwind-Config.js und eine Post-CSS-Config.js.
Alles klar.
This will create minimal Tailwind-Config.
Keine Sorge, wir machen das nicht mit Vim.
Wir machen das gleich mit VSCode.
Aber ich will mal gucken, ob das stimmt, was die da erzählen.
Genau.
Passt.
Alles klar.
Hat er erstellt.
Post-CSS-Config.
Hat er auch erstellt.
Nix drin.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob ich Post-CSS-Plugins brauche.
Ich wusste bis eben noch nicht mal, dass Post-CSS überhaupt existiert.
Configure Tailwind to remove unused styles input.
Ach was.
Ich hab gern 15 MB Webseiten.
Das bleibt so.
Include Tailwind in your CSS.
Wait.
Was?
Create Source Index CSS.
Okay.
Source?
Was?
Index CSS?
Und da soll ich den Kram jetzt reinpasten?
Okay.
Warum genau hat es dieser NPM-Generator nicht gemacht für mich?
Aha.
Finally in your main...
Ach hier, da soll ich das importieren.
Okay.
Ich war einfach nur Tutorial-Held.
Ja.
Also.
You're finished.
Echt.
Das war's schon.
Nur fünf kryptische Sachen machen müssen.
Okay.
NPM run dev.
Alles klar.
Excellent.
Und jetzt?
Aha.
Und das ist jetzt...
Oh.
Poggers Test-App.
So.
Excellent.
Okay.
Nice.
Und das war's jetzt, oder wie?
Alles klar.
Gut.
Dann machen wir das Ganze mal auf.
Beste Webseite.
Ja.
So.
Dann machen wir den ganzen Krempel hier mal auf.
Machen wir Visual Studio Code auf.
Und schieben das mal auf den Desktop.
Hier machen wir run npm dev.
Waren das Ding in Chrome auch.
Schieben es auch auf den dritten Desktop.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wenigstens so live reload und so.
Okay.
So.
Wenn ich jetzt hier oben reinschreibe KekW, dann steht dann da nicht KekW.
Doch da, da steht KekW.
Tatsächlich, okay.
Also Live Reload funktioniert.
Gut, wie funktioniert das jetzt mit Tailwind?
Ich habe legit keinen Plan.
Ich habe nur mal gesehen, man braucht unbedingt irgendeine Tailwind Extension,
weil sonst dreht man durch, weil man sich nicht merken kann, was es alles gibt.
Install.
Excellent.
So, und nun schmeißen wir die ganze Krempel erstmal raus, würde ich sagen.
Brauchen wir alles nicht.
Oh, das ist Vue.js 3 Composition API.
Habe ich noch nichts mitgemacht.
Ich bin ja so richtig Kacknoob, der noch bei Vue 2 hängen geblieben ist.
Was sagst du zu Jetbrains?
Die Jetbrains Sachen sind richtig nice.
Wo kommt denn das Bild her?
Wo kommt das Bild her?
Mein Template ist leer.
KekW.
Ah, ja.
Da kommt das her.
Ich dachte, ich bin schon in der App-View.
Hello World, Braumagard.
Hier, das ist alles weg.
Alles weg.
So, excellent.
So, alles fort.
Okay, also.
Dann können wir mal anfangen.
Also ich habe ernsthaft keine Ahnung.
Also H1, Kek, Wait.
So.
Warum ist das nicht groß?
Okay, Class.
Und was gibt es jetzt?
Oh, das sind die ganzen Tailwind-Classes.
Ach du.
What the fuck?
Ach du Scheiße, wer soll sich das denn merken?
Was macht der Template-Tag?
Da kommt das ganz normale HTML-Zeug rein.
Für eine Vue-Component.
Also jede Komponente in Vue besteht aus einem Style-Tag, einem Script-Tag und einem Template-Tag.
Und das ist alles, wenn du es nicht anders, also hier muss man eigentlich noch scoped hinschreiben.
Das ist dann alles nur für diese Komponente zugänglich.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier CSS reinschreibe, dann gilt das nur hier und nicht in einer anderen Komponente und sowas.
Okay, also extrem viel.
Das heißt Text.
Was gibt es mit Text?
Text, XS.
Oh.
Ah, so macht man das.
X, Text, XL, 9.
Bam, Kek, Wait, Alter.
Aha, verstehe, verstehe.
So funktioniert der Kram.
Gibt es auch sowas wie Center?
Text, Center?
Oh.
Ist die CSS nicht riesig?
Doch.
Deswegen haben die hier einen Guide drin, dass wenn du das quasi dann mit Production Environment bildest,
dass der den ganzen unbenutzten Kram wieder löscht.
Aktuell ist es wohl riesig groß, ja.
Allerdings habe ich keine Ahnung, wie ich in einem White-Projekt überhaupt ein Port-Bild mache, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie funktioniert denn das überhaupt?
NPM.
Run.
Bild oder so.
Oh, tatsächlich.
Okay, gucken wir mal, wie groß das jetzt ist.
Text.
Okay, das ist für eine Webseite, wo nichts drin ist, doch ein bisschen groß.
3,1 MB.
Auf der anderen Seite Facebook ist, glaube ich, 16 MB oder so.
Und die Leute verwenden es trotzdem.
Aber dann machen wir mal, was die hier reingeschrieben haben.
Wenn man bildet.
Purge.
Hier.
In your Tailwind Config File Config Purge Option.
Okay.
Tree Shake.
Alles klar.
Lichtmonka Shake Tree Shake.
Ja, es steht...
Also.
Also, Tailwind Config.
Wo muss das hin?
Purge.
Ich lasse jetzt einfach mal das Default drin.
Ja.
Bild.
Ah, mal gucken, wie groß es jetzt ist.
Okay.
Okay, das ist schon besser.
72.
72K.
Und Brotli zippt.
Noch weniger, oder?
Ja, Gzip ist aus.
Heute Brotli zippt man.
Also, wenn ihr mal klassische Webdesign-Kunst sehen wollt,
dann müsst ihr dahin.
Ja.
Da könnt ihr euch beispielsweise...
Könnt ihr euch zum Beispiel Netscapes...
Ah, fuck, ist das gerade kaputt?
Oh, es ist gerade kaputt anscheinend.
Guck mal, die haben nicht...
Okay, die Webdesign ist gerade kaputt.
Aber wenn ihr mal Oldschool-Internet-Zeug sehen wollt,
dann das hier, ja.
Nee, das ist anscheinend irgendwie gerade.
Sign Guestbook.
Excellent.
So, da könnt ihr euch mal klassisches Webdesign angucken.
Welches Film würdest du empfehlen, der noch nicht viel mit GS...
View.
Das sage ich als jemand, der von React und Englisch spricht.
Weil Englisch keine Ahnung hat.
Und ich jetzt auch nicht...
Also, ich versuche in letzter Zeit immer mehr Frontend-Sachen zu machen.
Erstens, weil es mir Spaß macht.
Und zweitens, weil man an Frontend-Sachen eh nicht mehr komplett...
Gar nicht mehr vorbeikommt.
Und ich habe mit View angefangen und finde View super.
Das Schöne, was mir an View persönlich...
Warum ich das auch zum Einstieg genommen habe, ist,
du kannst mit View anfangen ohne irgendwelche Bildtools.
Du kannst einfach...
Du kannst einfach eine stinknormale HTML-Seite nehmen.
Script-Tag reinmachen.
Das hier.
Und dann New View...
Muss man Beispiel angucken.
Und dann einfach Inline im HTML schreiben.
Das heißt, du brauchst gar nichts.
Und du brauchst keine Bundler, keine Webpack und sonstige Dinger.
Zum Anfang zumindest.
Mach mal Flutter Dart Stream.
Flutter wollte ich mit...
Das steht schon seit Ewigkeiten in der...
Stream-Sachen drin.
Okay.
Also, haben die so einen...
Die haben doch bestimmt irgendwie so einen Guide, wie es...
Wow.
A busy feel?
Sieht das bei mir auch so aus, wenn ich das da reinpaste?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Kack, wait.
Warum reloadet das nicht?
Oh.
Ach, ich kack nur, weil ich es beendet habe, lul.
Postchamp?
Ey, das sieht bei mir tatsächlich so aus.
Wie bei den...
Bloß das Logo fehlt noch.
Okay, nice.
Also, also.
So, was kann...
Was?
Was kann man damit jetzt machen?
Ich bin unkreativ.
Wir versuchen jetzt mal...
Wir versuchen jetzt mal eine Navigationsbar zu stylen.
Okay.
Responsive Design, bla bla.
Dark Mode.
Dark Mode ist auch immer gut.
Using Talents, you assess to style your site in Dark Mode.
Ah, und wie schaltet man dann um?
Toggling Dark Mode.
What?
Kack, was?
Wo ist der Button zum Umschalten?
Das ist mir zu big brain, Alter.
Ah, hier.
Okay, das ist die ganz klassische Geschichte.
Ich setze irgendwo einfach was auf Dark und dann wird es Dark.
Okay.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt mal mit etwas Simplem anfangen.
Was ich jetzt als Nicht-Design-Mensch auch machen kann.
Also, wir machen jetzt mal...
Wir machen jetzt mal...
Ein Button.
Wir machen jetzt eine Navigationsleiste und ein paar Buttons drin.
Was gibt es eigentlich für Icons?
Haben die Icons?
Dabei?
Hero-Icon.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Das ist, glaube ich, von den Tailwind-Leuten direkt dabei.
Okay, Search-Icon.
Kack.
Oh.
Äh, Stonks.
Fast.
Chartbar.
Was, Copy?
Was?
Copy?
Was hat er jetzt kopiert?
Ah.
Oh.
Alter, warum ist das so fett?
Huge, huge Item.
Äh.
Das habe ich schon mal in irgendeinem Tutorial gelesen.
Da kann man jetzt so etwas sagen wie Höhe 6, Breite...
Ah, genau, genau, genau.
Aha.
Okay, so kann man das Ding...
Jetzt kann ich jetzt auch sagen Text-Center.
Ne, das funktioniert nicht.
Warum nicht?
Warum kann ich das jetzt nicht centern und das andere kann ich centern?
Ach, wahrscheinlich, weil es kein Text ist, hä?
Okay, ich bin absolut planlos, was sowas angeht.
Aber das ist schon mal ein Icon.
Schon mal gut.
Und...
Align-Middle.
Ach, ne, das ist jetzt...
What?
Align-Center gibt's nicht.
Ne, ne, das...
Aber mit Flex wird's wahrscheinlich dann funktionieren.
Genau, das würde funktionieren.
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Oh.
Flex-Box-Champ.
Okay, klar.
Wie geht das jetzt?
Ah, die...
Einfach nur Flex.
Flex.
Irgendwie Justif...
Ne, wie geht das?
Just...
Justify?
Ne, äh...
Moment, ich bin Kack-Noob, was Flex-Box angeht.
Äh...
Warte mal, warte mal.
Flex?
Ne, Row ist Default.
Wild am Rum-Flex.
Justify?
Center?
Ah!
Okay, okay, verstehe, verstehe.
So, da kann man jetzt unseren H1, wenn wir das da noch reinmachen, dann...
Keck-Weight.
Wow, ich bin so schlecht, was das angeht.
Ähm...
Okay.
Ich bräuchte mal irgendeinen...
Irgend so einen, so einen Starting-Guide.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, wir gehen das jetzt hier einfach mal der Reihe nach durch und lesen uns das durch, weil ich checke, check gar nichts.
Also, wie gesagt, wir machen, wir machen mal eine Navigationsleiste.
Wie sieht das eigentlich mit den Fonts aus?
Hat Tailwind standardmäßig Fonts oder ist das irgendwie ein...
Oh.
Oder ist das einfach das, was auf dem System installiert ist?
Äh, bin ich jetzt verwirrt?
Ging das im Chrome nicht?
Man konnte doch im Chrome, oder war das nur im Firefox, man konnte doch dynamisch Klassen hinzufügen, ohne dass man sie hier reinschreiben muss, wo man dann auch sehen konnte, was es für Klassen gibt.
Ne, ne, ne, das meine ich nicht.
Dann hatte man hier so ein Menü.
Das da meine ich, das da meine ich.
Genau.
Das hier.
Add new class.
Genau.
Da kann man das nämlich, da kann man das nämlich ausprobieren.
Ähm, da kann ich sowas sagen wie hier, äh, bold.
Oder, oder, text.
Sowas wie bold.
Blue.
Boah, das ist nice.
Da kann man das nämlich dynamisch ausprobieren hier, den ganzen Kram, ohne dass man das permanent im Editor machen muss.
Okay, das ist, das ist im Prinzip die Größe.
Das andere Font.
Wenn es nicht...
Ah.
Ich muss sagen, ich finde, also, das macht auf mich den durchdachten Eindruck.
Ich habe zwar keine Ahnung von Designsachen.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man schnell was ausprobiert...
Probieren will.
Ist das wirklich extrem nice.
So, sagen wir mal, Font.
Ex...
Semibold.
Und wie geht das dann hier?
Einfach Font.
Ah, genau so.
Okay, excellent, excellent.
Verstehe.
Okay.
Jetzt müssen wir mal kurz das, das Tutorial hier irgendwie durchgehen.
Gut, hier, hier erklären sie uns jetzt, dass...
Das ist tatsächlich eine Frage, die ich mir stelle.
Warum man nicht einfach...
Inline Styles verwenden sollte.
Anstatt Tailwind.
Weil ich meine, ob ich jetzt das mache oder Inline Styles, ist doch gar kein so großer Unterschied.
Okay.
Ja, genau.
Das, das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht.
Ist das nicht einfach Inline Styles?
Und sie geben zu, es ist es.
Okay, ja, das ist schon mal nice.
Da lag ich schon mal nicht so falsch.
Ja gut, dafür kann ich mit Inline Styles aber machen.
Responsive Design.
You can't use media queries in Inline Styles.
Ach.
Ah.
Okay.
Das ist cool.
Das ist nice.
Also, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, kann ich quasi die Schriftgröße abhängig machen von der Größe des Browserfensters.
Und das Ganze ohne JavaScript.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Also, wir sagen, es ist, es ist, ähm...
Auf MD ist es Text Size 4.
Also, nee, warte mal.
Default ist Text Size...
Warte mal, anders.
Texts...
Ist 4.
Und auf Large ist es Texts 8.
Ey.
Guck mal, das ist nice.
Ganz, ganz ohne JavaScript-Gedöns.
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist wirklich cool.
Das ist nice.
Das gefällt mir schon mal.
Das ist für die ganzen Responsive-Leute ist das super.
Okay, das ist nice.
Und keine eigenen Media-Queries oder so.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Das, das hat was.
Hover, Focus and Other States.
Ach, sprich, ich kann jetzt auch direkt sowas angeben wie, ähm...
Hover.
Und dann sagen wir irgendwie Red.
Oder, oder Text.
Text Red.
100.
Ey, das ist nice.
Das ist, das ist nice.
Das ist nice.
Das kann man zwar alles auch so machen.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine deutlich kürzere,
und knackigere Art, als das mit, mit CSS selbst zu machen.
Ich meine, für das erste, für das hier mit dem Text,
da müsste ich irgendwelche Media-Queries schreiben.
Hier, Add Media, äh, Screen Size, bla.
Und für das zweite müsste ich quasi eine eigene Klasse anlegen.
Irgendwie, äh, H1, äh, Hover.
Ne, äh, oh, wie geht denn das?
Hover.
Und dann den Kram hier machen.
Da ist das schon, das ist schon netter.
Warum 600? Ich vermute mal, dass das die Intensität ist.
Guck, es gibt von 50...
Dann siehst du hier kaum was, dass es rot ist.
Von 50 bis, keine Ahnung, 600 oder so.
Das ist cool, das gefällt mir, das hat echt was.
Geht das auch, geht das auch mit dem Icon hier?
Ah, guck mal, das geht auch mit dem Icon.
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir, das hat was.
Das ist cool, okay.
Ah, schon mal Pluspunkt, schon mal Pluspunkt.
Fokus.
Inline Styles, Kent, Targets, Hover oder Fokus.
Okay, wir könnten auch noch mal ein Formular machen.
Aber das ist cool.
Also da haben sie mich schon mal überzeugt, dass das eine gute Idee ist, was sie sich da überlegt haben.
Übrigens, der neue PogChamp Komodo Hype hat gewonnen.
So, ein weiterer Vorteil ist, dass ich einfach Components extracten lasse.
Okay, das stimmt.
Das können wir tatsächlich nochmal ausprobieren.
We won.
Also sprich, wenn wir jetzt einen Button machen zum Beispiel.
Button.
Der, der, der, der Keg Weight Button.
Ne, der Keg Weight haben wir schon.
Der Lull Button.
Das ist ein Button, das sieht natürlich ungestylt und ziemlich crappy aus.
So, das heißt, wir können den jetzt irgendwie anderweitig stylen.
Also sprich, Background.
Das ist ein schöner Background.
Blue 800.
Oh ja, exzellent.
Border.
Round.
Oh.
Hier.
Größe 16.
Breite 16.
Massive Button.
Okay, machen wir mal Höhe lieber 10.
Max am Frontend Poggers.
So, und wie machen wir jetzt die Texts?
Texts?
White.
Okay, es sieht kacke aus.
Ja, aber.
So, Outline.
Wie macht man das Outline aus?
Outline.
Outline Non.
Äh.
Keg Weight.
Ah, das ist jetzt Fokus.
Das ist jetzt Fokus.
Das muss ich wahrscheinlich auch ausschalten.
Ih, warum, warum macht denn das hier?
Zeilenumbrüche.
Fokus.
Outline Non.
Oh, cool.
Nice, nice.
Das, das gefällt mir.
Das gefällt mir.
Ähm.
Ich mach mal kurz das Icon hier unten weg.
Ups.
So.
Äh, und wie kriege ich da jetzt Abstand dazwischen?
Sag mal, hier dazwischen wollen wir jetzt noch, äh, Marchen.
Marchen Bottom.
Soll ich 10?
Ah, nice.
Okay, ich gebe zu, das, äh, wirklich schöner Button ist es nicht, aber, äh, es ist ein Button.
Ja.
Äh.
Nein, nein, kein neuer Preis, Champ.
Aber das ist, das ist cool.
Okay, und jetzt können wir noch sagen, äh, was war das?
Font Bold?
Bold?
Ah.
Ey, komm, das geht doch jetzt schon mal als Button irgendwie durch.
Wie, wie mache ich denn da jetzt einen Klick?
Wie mache ich da jetzt eine, eine, eine, eine Klick-Animation?
Und ab wann macht das mal einen Seitenumbruch?
Ich meine, das ist ganz schön, ganz schön lang.
Ähm.
Klick?
Nee.
Hm.
Wie macht man da jetzt einen...
Einen...
Fokus?
Ach, stimmt.
Fokus.
Genau.
Und dann...
Wie, Shadow?
Kann man so was...
Hehe.
Äh.
Aber habe ich das da hinten nicht schon?
Fokus.
Outline.
Non.
Fokus.
Äh.
Ja, was ist so gut?
Was ist so ein gutes Ding?
Was, was...
Ring?
Was macht denn ein Ring?
Wow.
Nee.
Es ist nicht Fokus.
Äh.
Wie, wie, wie macht man denn 10?
Wie macht man in CSS, wie macht man in CSS einen, einen Buttonklick?
Äh.
CSS Buttonklick.
Oh.
Nee.
Hofer meine ich nicht.
Ich meine, wenn man draufklickt.
Fokus.
Active.
Nee.
Active?
Was kann ich?
Nee.
Das geht nicht.
Active?
Nee.
Das ist das, was macht, wenn ich draufklick.
Okay.
Tailwind Buttonklick.
Hofer Fokus Other States.
Ja.
Okay.
Hör auf.
Guck mal hier.
Der.
Der sagt...
Äh...
Ich will, dass der Button nicht dauerhaft leuchtet.
Ich will.
Ich, ich will, dass der Button einfach nur was macht, wenn ich draufklick.
Okay.
Da gehts schon los.
Der Buttonstruggle ist real Alter.
Button.
Jao.
Wobei.
Eigentlich muss der Button nix machen.
Das ist hofer.
Aber Active, Active kann er doch nicht oder?
Was macht er eigentlich needed, der أو?
Weiß ich nicht, Alter.
Aktiv? Aktiv kann er nicht. Nee, Aktiv kann er nicht.
Okay, das doch.
Aktiv kann man in der Config aktivieren.
Ah, guck mal.
By default, Aktiv-Variant is not enabled for any core-Plugins.
Äh, Moment, was?
Und was ist, wenn ich es für alles aktiviert haben will?
Tailwind macht quasi, dass man kann es jetzt erstmal...
Anscheinend schon, ja.
Äh, the name is Fabi.
Twitch Prime... Nee, kein Prime.
So, Subscriptions. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription.
Also, jetzt gehe ich in meine Tailwind-Config.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Ich gehe in meine Tailwind-Config.
Oh.
Und dann mache ich was?
Variants.
Extend.
Background-Color-Active.
Und jetzt geht das?
Hopp.
Hey!
Okay, die Button-Kombination ist vielleicht nicht so glücklich, was ich da gebastelt habe.
Aber, ähm, man.
Ich kenn's.
So, wir machen jetzt was, was stylischeres.
Excellent.
Massive-Styler-Button machen wir jetzt.
BG-Blue-500.
Sieht schon fast Bootstrap-mäßig aus, das Blau, oder?
Das ist so ein typisches Bootstrap-Blau.
So, und BG-Active.
Ach, jetzt kapiere ich das.
Kann ich, kann ich es, kann ich es einfach, kann ich es für alles aktivieren?
Das Extend, dass ich einfach nur sage, Active?
So, ohne irgendwas?
Ja, oder es wird nicht funktionieren.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ich kann es nicht für alles aktivieren.
Vielleicht, vielleicht gibt es auch ein bisschen zu viele Klassen, hä?
Vielleicht Sternchen, sowas hier?
Äh, oder gequotet, gequotet?
Aha.
Okay, was ist denn da, was ist denn da ein schöner, schöner, wenn man, was sieht denn schön aus, wenn man draufklickt?
BG-Blue, sowas hier.
Ey, das ist doch ein, das ist doch ein nicer Button.
Das ist doch ein schicker Button jetzt, oder?
Exquisite.
So, und nun?
Komm, jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Hover-Effekt.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Hover-Effekt.
Äh, irgendeinen Shadow.
Was kann der Button jetzt?
Geklickt werden, das war's.
Das ist, es geht nur um Style, also nur um Optik hier.
Da ist absolut nichts funktionier-
Was wir als nächstes probieren, wir machen da eine View-Klasse draus, die wir dann-
Dass wir dann überall den Button verwenden können.
Wo der Mehrwert gegenüber Viewtify ist.
Da bin ich mir selbst noch nicht so ganz sicher.
Ich glaube, es gibt keinen Mehrwert in dem Sinn.
Äh, Viewtify kann deutlich mehr.
Viewtify sind halt komplett fertige, äh, View-Components, die alle möglichen 30 Milliarden Funktionen haben.
Ähm, und das ist einfach nur Design-Gedöns.
So, also das haben wir schon.
Excellent Button.
So, jetzt machen wir noch einen Hover-Effekt.
Sag mal, macht das irgendwann auch mal Zeilenumbruch?
Ich mein, what?
Wie lang muss denn das noch werden, dass der mal einen Zeilenumbruch da rein macht?
Ich mein, what the hell?
Please, Zeilenumbruch!
Kann ich selbst Zeilenumbrüche machen?
Nee.
Was ist das für ein scheiß Formatter?
Was, Alt-Z?
Ach.
Ach, Alt-Z, ist das der Line-
Ähm, nee, das will ich nicht.
Ich will keine Line-
Ich will keinen Wrap an den Zeilen haben.
Ich will, dass der-
Dass meine, mein, ähm-
On-Save formatiert.
Never gonna Zeilenumbruch.
Äh, das ist irgendein Formatter-
Formatter-Settings.
Settings.
So.
Format.
Formatting.
Format und Save.
Ja.
Format, wo haben wir es denn?
Wo ist, wo ist, wo ist JavaScript?
Wie?
Okay, great.
Ach, nee, Moment.
Wo ging das nochmal?
Pretty?
Äh.
Jyoti?
F50?
Das ist die Settings-Jason.
Kann man das hier vielleicht drin einstellen?
Was der, was da zum Formatieren verwendet?
And das ist ja das View-Plugin.
Prettier.
Ja?
Und, und, und wie stelle ich die Prettier-Config ein?
Prettier.
OKS.
Äh.
Und, und, und wie stelle ich da jetzt was um?
Okay.
JS Code.
Prettier Settings
Auto-Config Prettier, okay. Excellent. Okay, was hat denn der noch? Was hat denn der hier noch? Okay
Was kann der sonst noch haben? Pretty HTML
JS-Pewtify HTML, meinetwegen, ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal
Ich will einfach nur, dass der Line-Breaks macht, Alter
Also manchmal ist es echt schon hardcore kompliziert
Line-Break-Class-HTML
How to prevent, nein, nein, nein, ich will, ich will es nicht preventen, ich will das machen
Print with, okay, was?
Wo bin ich hier gelandet jetzt?
Meine Fresse, Alter
Ich check nichts
Ich habe die externe, ja, aber irgendwas macht ja mein Formatieren on safe
HTML Format Wrap, aha
Maximum of Allowed Characters per Line
Okay
Dann gucken wir mal, ob wir, ob wir es schaffen, über 100, wie viel
Wie viel sind das jetzt? Wir sind doch schon drüber, da sollte es eigentlich jetzt umbrechen, macht er aber nicht
Juckt ihr nicht, ist ihm egal
Okay, das ist krass kompliziert, hätte ich nicht gedacht
Ruby
Und vor allem, was auch nervig ist, dass er das, dass ich nicht selbst Line-Breaks machen darf
Okay, das, das sagt man. Also dieses Setting greift anscheinend nicht. Tja, ich bin echt absolut ratlos, wo ich das jetzt einstelle
Das brauche ich auf jeden Fall, sonst, sonst siehst du ja gar nix mehr
Installiere einfach Prettier, okay, na Quatsch hier
Prettier Code Format, das Ding
Install, bäm
Exquisite
Okay, und jetzt gehe ich hier in die Settings von meiner, von meiner View Extension, wer sollte das eigentlich gecheckt haben, oder?
Oder auch nicht
Jetzt nochmal neu starten, oder was?
Ich hasse teilweise Frontend-Gefrickel, ey
so nein ich will keinen docker installieren darf nicht rum so also machen tut jetzt noch
nix kann ich jetzt in den settings irgendwie einstellen dass der für man view js zeug den
kram verwenden verwendet kebab case alles klar aber verwendet er das jetzt schon jeder verwendet
das schon anscheinend kann ich jetzt in die british settings gehen und das einstellen oder
was ok also wird das sind 30 milliarden sachen aber das greift nicht das ist weiter als 80
zeichen ist mir zu dumm das wäre echt zu dumm warum kann man das warum gibt es nicht einfach
ein setting für arbeit jetzt geht jetzt jetzt geht formatieren und safe gar nicht mehr kommt
mal ist formatieren
und safe komplett kaputt jetzt kann ich jetzt kann ich zwar selbst einrücken aber selbst da
gar nicht mehr das ist so eklig das gefrickel das kann doch nicht sein so weg zu erleben gleich atom
genau jetzt geht's wieder rake line class ich habe keine ahnung was wie es geht das kann doch echt
nicht so
schwer sein,
das
wer hat sich das wieder ausgedacht
und wahrscheinlich gibts das setting aber keine ahnung wurde es
mit der steckt
eh ja
i
ich hasse so rumgefônashed
fallen wenn das absolut undurchsichtig ist
ich mein das ist die ex十 v lo twisted ones
Und warum gibt es da nicht ein Setting für Line Break?
Puck.
Aber Hauptsache es kann fucking Puck
formatieren, ja?
Ah, hier, guck mal.
Default Format der Options.
Options for all...
Ne, das ist hier...
Style...
Nein, ich will einfach, dass der meine HTML-Zeug
umbricht.
Du kannst 50 Billiarden
Sachen einstellen, ja?
Aber es gibt
kein Settings, dass der
Klass-Dinger um Line Break
Was passiert, wenn ich das
jetzt umstelle auf Pretty HTML?
Was passiert dann?
Dann macht er irgendwie was ganz
was anderes, okay.
Was passiert, wenn ich das hier umstelle auf
äh...
auf None? Okay, macht er dann?
Nichts.
Das funktioniert schon mal.
Das ist immerhin...
So.
JS-Beautify-HTML.
Okay.
Ah!
Alles klar.
Er sieht zwar hässlich als fuck aus, aber...
Ja, er hat's geline-breaked.
Ne, er hat's nicht geline-breaked.
Ey.
Ich... ich... ich aninstall das
gleich, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Was ist Puck? Puck ist
für Leute, die HTML kacke
fanden, ein HTML mit
mit, äh, Zeilen, mit, äh,
Python-Style, äh,
äh, Einrückungen.
So, Leute, noch irgendjemand,
eine glorreiche Idee, wie man das
einstellen kann.
Template-Breakline-Class-Format.
Der Klade erkennt das.
Hab ich doch hier umgestellt.
Wenn ich das umstelle, erkennt das doch auch.
Warum soll er eine View-Extension...
Ja, weil es es offensichtlich macht.
Beziehungsweise zumindest
den, den, den das auswählt
für Formatieren. So, jetzt ist natürlich die
große Preisfrage.
Also, wo kann ich dem jetzt sagen,
wo HTML-Format... Wo sind
Settings für
den Standard-Prettier,
Prettier, Prettier, wie auch immer.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das macht,
Alter. VS Code.
Gehen wir mal.
Gehen wir bloß fort mit ES-Lint, Alter.
Das macht's jetzt auch nicht besser.
Okay, also, also, jetzt, jetzt
kriegen wir's erklärt. Jetzt kriegen wir's erklärt.
Big Brain. Also, haben wir gemacht.
At the following settings
to enter Prettier is used for holding all code times.
Okay.
What? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Was, über das Zahnrad in der Extension?
Welches Zahnrad?
Du meinst das da?
Nee, oder?
Da kommst du hier raus. Da kommst du hier raus.
Da kommst du, wenn du das, wenn du das,
wenn du das, wenn du das hier machst,
da kommst du genau hier raus.
Oh.
PrettierRC. Ich will doch keine Config
in meinem Projekt anlegen, dass der
den fucking Zeilenumbruch macht.
Ich, ich glaub's nicht, ey.
Stimmt, weil man legt da vielleicht schon
irgendeine Prettier-Datei rum, ne, gell?
Hä? Ja, da komm ich doch genau,
wenn ich hier draufklicke und jetzt auf Settings
oder wie auch immer, da komm ich doch genau hier raus.
Da, wo ich schon drinnen war.
Und da kann man nur
auswählen, was der für den Prettier
verwendet. Klar sind Linebreaks
erlaubt. Oder?
Doch.
Klar sind Linebreaks erlaubt.
Ich hab, ich hab legit keine Ahnung.
Wir machen das jetzt auch nicht, weil sonst
das dauert noch ewig.
Aber manchmal fuckt mich dieser
Frontend-Kram echt richtig ab bei sowas.
Nein. Boah, ist, ist, ist
das zu viel verlangt, da eine ordentliche Option
für irgendwo hinzubauen, dass man sagt
hier, Linebreaks, easy. So.
Fertig. Nein. Kann halt so
schwer sein. Selbst wenn ich so
einen Kack haben will, keine Ahnung,
jedes Attribut auf eine Zeile, meinetwegen,
dann sollst du es halt machen.
Aber man erkennt halt nix.
So, jetzt haben wir
zumindest mal einen huge, meinen huge Button
am Start. Ich wollte jetzt noch gucken, dass
wenn das Ding gehovert wird.
Also, hover.
Nee, nee, nicht BG.
Also, wenn das gehovert wird, dann
was sieht denn cool bei einem Button aus?
Irgendein Shadow oder so, hä?
Kann man sowas machen?
Oh, guck mal!
Massive. Seht ihr das?
Massive Shadow im Hintergrund, wenn man
hovert.
Man erkennt's nicht wirklich, aber
man könnte, was kann man machen,
dass es cool aussieht, wenn man hovert?
Wie macht denn das ein Bootstrap?
Wie sieht das in
Beautify nochmal aus, wenn man einen Button hovert?
Ich hab, was so Design-Sachen
angeht, ich bin voll
bladenlos. Ah, okay.
Wenn man hovert, wird das leicht
grau, oder ansonsten
wenn man klickt, wird's dann richtig
dunkel. Okay.
Was HTML
Widespace-Sensitivity, also wenn das
ernsthaft so heißt,
Widespace-Sensi...
Nee, doch.
Nee,
was?
Was soll ich machen?
Okay, also Extensions HTML.
Also, ich hab keine Ahnung, was du meinst.
Format HTML Format Wrap Line Length.
Oh, was ist denn da der Default?
Ich will ja nicht die, ich will ja nicht,
dass er die die Line automatisch
rappt, der soll, warte mal, man konnte
doch irgendwo hier in die Settings so
rein, hab ich eigentlich für ganzen Müll
drin stehen.
Wrap 20.
Das ist dem scheißegal.
Das juckt dir nicht.
Aber das ist jetzt 100.
Der macht, der macht innerhalb von der Klasse
macht er keinen Zeilenumbruch.
Das ist dem...
Das schon mal nicht.
Was soll ich machen?
White?
Nee.
Was?
Widespace?
Existiert nicht, was du schreibst.
Also, ich hab keinen Plan, wie das funktioniert.
Also ich hab keinen Plan, wie das funktioniert.
funktioniert. Ernsthaft, das leuchtet mir in Null ein.
Also, ich glaube,
dass prinzipiell Zeilenumbrüche,
wenn sie länger als 120
sind,
sehr super,
dass die sogar funktionieren,
äh, wo ist das Problem jetzt?
Achso, meint, das ist Closed.
Dass der das prinzipiell schon macht,
hier mit dem Zeilenumbruch.
Ja, aber,
oder, oder, ah, Mann,
darf man das
wirklich nicht umbrechen?
Doch, oder?
Leute, darf man, darf man, darf man hier
New Lines reinmachen, oder ist das nicht erlaubt?
Weil sollte das nicht erlaubt sein,
wäre das echt nervig.
Wartet mal.
Kann das sein, dass das gar nicht geht?
Dass er das eigentlich richtig macht?
Format?
Nein.
Doch, klar, es ist erlaubt,
du hast kein Problem.
Weil ich meine, gerade, gerade wenn du da mit
Tailwind 30 Milliarden Klassen da drauf hast,
dann muss, muss man das doch machen, ne?
Prettier, prettierier.
Zeigst mal.
Settings.
Jison.
Ähm, na gut, da kann ich ja nichts einstellen,
das hab ich ja nicht installiert.
Als, als ich das installiert hab,
ähm,
war er der Meinung, Auto-Format geht gar nicht mehr.
Die HTML.
Format.
So, was gibt's da?
Enable.
Und extra.
Intent, äh, innerHTML, was auch immer.
Preserve Templating.
Wrap Attributes.
Ha!
Okay.
Äh, okay, macht das jetzt was?
Nein.
Wobei, das sind ja keine Attributes, ne?
Was ich da hab.
Das sind ja keine Attributes.
Das sind ja, äh, was auch immer.
Ray Money, ich kann doch überhaupt keine Prettier Settings machen.
Ich hab doch dieses komische Plugin gar nicht installiert.
Und ich seh's auch nicht ein, dass ich ein Plugin installiere dafür, dass ich,
äh, meine, meine Klassen-Line-Breaken kann.
Das macht schon mal nix.
Nee, das Format ist bestimmt an.
Das ist bestimmt an.
Ich kann das nicht auslagern.
Das muss alles an diesen Button dran.
Hier ist Co-
Class-Line-Break.
Mal gucken, ob's dazu was gibt.
Richtig räudig, äh.
Ist der?
Aha.
Das ist zu, also, Leute.
Das ist zu Big Brain für mich.
Ich bin nicht in der Lage,
weil,
hehehe,
den Krabi ordentlich formatieren zu lassen.
Das geht nicht.
Unmöglich.
Geil.
Was auch immer.
Ich hab nicht mal ESLint installiert.
Beziehungsweise in dem Projekt drinnen.
Aber schon geil. Ist schon geil.
Also, das ist, das ist,
Das ist Next Level Big Brain Kram.
Das ist, das ist, das ist Next Level Big Brain Kram.
Weil das hätte schon seinen Vorteil.
Bei, bei, bei, äh, bei Tailwind
willst du ja total viele Klassen hier reinschreiben.
Und das wird ja schon auch fast normal sein,
sowas hier zu schreiben.
Und,
und das kann doch nicht sein.
Leute, ich brauch noch, ich brauch noch einen coolen Hover-Effekt.
Ich brauch irgendeinen, irgendeinen Massive...
Was ist ein nice, nicer Hover-Effekt?
Äh, Borner?
Dass man unten einen Strich drunter macht,
oder sowas?
Was? Add, Apply?
Ach so. Ja. Nee.
Okay.
Das, da, da kann ich auch normales CSS machen.
So. Was, was, was, was ist ein schöner Hover-Hover-Style jetzt, Leute?
Hier. Big, Big Brain Chat Design.
Also ich mein, hellblau wird's beim, beim Klick...
Nee, wie... Ah, Leute, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Ich weiß, was wir machen. Also.
Active, Active... Moment.
Wir haben normales Blue 500.
Active wird auf jeden Fall schon mal Blue 600.
Ah, ja, sieht schon gleich besser aus, ne?
Nee. 700?
So.
Und, und Hover wird BG Blue 600.
Oh.
Guck hier.
Bam.
Bester Button.
NA.
Was ein krasser Button, ey.
So.
Transition.
Weil, klingt wie der Originalfarbe.
Ja, aber nur, nur wenn du runterhoverst.
Aber, so, soweit wollt ich jetzt gar nicht dran rumwurst.
Okay, wir haben nen Button.
Okay.
Ich, ich wollt, ich wollt ne Navi, ne Navigationsleiste eigentlich machen, um mal bisschen, bisschen was zu üben.
Ähm.
Okay.
Also, na, mach mal ne Navi, Navigationsleiste.
Oh.
Alles klar.
So, da kommt jetzt der Button rein.
Und das sieht schon mal scheiße aus.
Okay, wir, wir brauchen nen Button Component, sonst, sonst ist das absoluter Müll.
Schau mal da rein.
Was, was genau?
Also, für, für, für, für.
Da ist das Problem mit Kommas?
Welches?
Komma?
Welches Problem mit Komma?
Use to join classes.
Oh, what, what?
What?
OKS.
Das haben wir?
Die haben wir?
Headwind.
Ah, der, der saved, der, der sortiert das on save.
Na.
Oh, das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Wie?
Ich will dafür nichts bezahlen, Alter.
Alles klar.
Was bei Punkt 1?
Brainwind.
Also, Punkt 1 ist mir, ist mir zu ex, exquisite, ehrlich gesagt.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Für, ich soll so'n Crap schreiben für Zeilenumbruch?
Was ist mit denen los?
Hahaha.
Okay, okay.
Er soll einfach nen Zeilenumbruch machen, Alter.
Okay.
VSCode for, ich hab noch ne Idee.
Every class own line.
Separate, ja, ja, ja, so, ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
CSS class.
Separate line.
Das ist deutlich zu advanced für mich.
So.
So, ein einfaches Setting.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass es kein großer Akt ist, dass man das so einstellen kann.
Aber anscheinend doch.
Ich will's ja gar nicht own line.
Ich sag mal so, 4 Stück pro Zeile oder so.
Je nachdem, wie auch immer.
So, das ist line break, meinetwegen.
So, jetzt haben wir hier mal nen big brain Button am Start.
Der ist ja schon mal, der ist ja schon mal richtig advanced.
So, class.
So, jetzt machen wir mal margin.
Nee.
Äh.
Margin 4.
Okay.
Perfekt.
So, dann machen wir jetzt mal ne eigene View Component draus.
Aus dieser, aus diesem Button.
Also.
Component.
Wir, wir, wir missbrauchen dazu mal die Hello World Component.
Äh, Button.
Zack.
Ach, das ist, das ist diese neue, äh, neue Composition Geschichte.
Da hab ich keine Ahnung von, wie das funktioniert.
Ich, ich muss, ich muss da, ich muss da nen klassisches.
Ich muss da nen klassische View Component draus machen.
Weil, ansonsten bin ich absolut nicht in der Lage, das überhaupt.
Weil, keine Ahnung.
Hab ich auch nicht mit beschäftigt.
Ich bin immer noch auf View 2 hängen geblieben.
Ja, Word Rap funktioniert prinzipiell schon.
Also, Line Rap funktioniert.
Word Rap ist jetzt ja, äh, glaub ich nicht so das, was ich haben will.
Ich wills ja nur für Classes haben.
G, D, I, J, Z, Martin, 19 Monate.
Boah, so viel.
Das ist ja Hyper Subscription.
Hyper Subscriber.
So.
Äh, ich mach mal da ne normale View Component draus.
Weil ich sonst da zu, zu noobig für bin.
Gibt es, hat das eigentlich hier.
Hat das da irgendein, irgendein Makro für?
Ah ja, hier.
Excellent.
Kann ich nämlich den Kram rausschmeißen.
Ups.
Ah, das hab ich jetzt gemacht.
Template.
Zehn Monate.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Mark LDMN.
Huge Subs, Huge Subscriptions hier heute.
Ok.
Ähm.
Also.
Äh, ne.
Name.
Tja.
Wie heißt unsere Component?
Äh.
Einfach nur.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Template.
So.
Äh.
Und dann.
Tja.
Template.
So.
Äh.
Und dann.
Tja.
Template.
So.
Äh.
Text.
Ok.
Das ist jetzt keine sonderliche Massive Brain Component, aber immerhin.
Ähm.
Data.
Oh, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Return?
Ne.
Äh.
Ähm.
Oh Gott.
Aus dem Kopf, alter.
Äh.
Return?
So.
War das glaube.
Text.
Gucken wir mal kurz, ob das funktioniert.
Ach ne.
Ich brauche ja einen Prop.
Prop.
Props brauchen wir.
Ja.
Prop.
Text.
Data brauchen wir gar nicht.
So.
Jetzt haben wir unseren Button.
Gut.
Wunderbar.
Mehr brauchen wir glaube ich nicht.
Alles klar.
Ach so.
Umbenennen müssen wir das noch.
Äh.
Hello World.
Heißt nicht mehr Hello World, sondern Big Brain Button View.
Excellent.
So.
Jetzt können wir nämlich den Button wegmachen.
Äh.
Ah ne.
Import müssen wir es noch.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Text.
Hallo.
Cool.
Okay.
Jetzt muss ich den Kram noch importieren.
Äh.
Wie ging das jetzt hier?
Script.
Ich glaube Setup muss man dann wegmachen an der Stelle.
Import.
Äh.
Ach du große.
Wo ist der Kram denn?
Components.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Big.
Brain.
Button.
Oh ne.
Punkt View.
Äh.
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas vergessen?
Warum nicht Angular?
Kannste auch fragen.
Oder warum nicht jQuery?
Ach ne.
Warte mal.
Setup.
War das.
Reicht das nicht so?
Äh.
War das nicht alles was er machen musste?
Ach ja.
Ach stimmt.
Stimmt.
Kommt..
Aber das kann ich auch nicht.
Das is total bescheuert.
Was hab ich denn vergessen?
Das is irgendwie U3-Geschichte wahrscheinlich.
Was?
Export default keine Dinger.
Was.
Ernsthaft?
Excquisite Chat.
Der Chat ist wieder Massive Brain hier.
Okay.
Warum mekka da überhaupt, das es not used wird.
Natürlich wirds used.
Ich mein da unten nich.
Aber..
Okay jetzt ham wir hier den Button drinne.
Perfekt.
So, jetzt können wir hier nämlich alles mögliche reinschreiben an Text, was wir wollen.
Jetzt haben wir, okay, jetzt können wir hier 1, 2, 3, 4 Buttons machen.
Dann müssen wir gucken, dass die, okay, jetzt kann ich mal meine Flexbox-Skills ausprobieren.
Ähm, nee, warte mal, Padding jedes Element geht nicht, ne?
Also Flex, hallo, Flex.
So, und jetzt kommt mal was, Justify Center.
Und jetzt Space, Between oder irgendwie sowas.
Nee, ähm, Alter, Flex, Space, ach du große Kacke, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Between, Content, Just, nee, doch.
Nee, ich will aber Space, man konnte doch Space irgendwie dazwischen machen.
Was macht denn das, Space?
Ah, yes, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das jetzt macht.
Aber anscheinend, da kann ich mir eine Flexbox-Gedöns doch auch sparen, oder?
Ja, wobei, sonst besser.
Eine exzellente Navigationsleiste hier, besser, besser, also viel, viel nicer geht es ja ganz schön.
Äh, Start.
Und jetzt, äh, Margin, Left, 2.
Okay, ist der chill, aber funktioniert.
Okay, jetzt haben wir hier unsere tollen Buttons.
Also, das ist der Button für, keine Ahnung, für Home.
Äh, das ist der Button für, äh, Twitch, was auch immer.
Ich schreibe da jetzt mal irgendwas rein, keine Ahnung, YouTube.
Und das hier ist das Impressum natürlich, was sonst?
Oh, so, der ist, der ist nicht Agile genug.
Der Button, der, oh, der kapiert es nicht, der suckt.
Äh, da müssen wir die, die feste, feste Breite rausnehmen wahrscheinlich.
Okay.
Kann man, haben wir Mindestbreite, Min?
16 oder so?
Cool.
Wow.
MonkaS.
Wie, wie, wie kann ich ihm denn sagen, dass ich mindestens, mindestens 16 haben will?
Geht das überhaupt?
Okay, wir machen, wir machen das, BigBrain, wir machen einfach alles größer, dann passt es wieder.
Oh, ne, das geht nicht mehr.
Weh, was ist denn das Größte?
24.
Bam, perfekt.
Ja, wirklich responsive ist es nicht.
Hahaha.
Okay.
So.
Huge Navigationsleiste.
Okay.
So, wie krieg ich da jetzt Icons rein?
Moment.
Icons.
Wie war das?
Hero Icon?
Äh, haben die sowas wie YouTube?
Ne.
Impressum.
Video, ist das egal.
Video.
Fuck.
Ich mein, da kann ich bestimmt auch Material Design Icons reinmachen, ne?
Das dürfte wahrscheinlich kein Problem sein.
Ähm.
Wie krieg ich denn jetzt den...
Wow.
Moment.
Wie krieg ich denn da jetzt den...
Das sieht mega beschissen aus.
Hahaha.
Wie krieg ich denn das jetzt auf die gleiche Zeile?
Äh...
Class.
Okay, okay, nice.
Excellent, excellent.
Hey, das sieht doch gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Bloß die Gesamtbreite ein bisschen...
Bisschen, bisschen hier, keine Ahnung, was gibt's da noch?
Zwei...
Acht...
Ja, jetzt sieht's doch gut aus.
32, jawoll.
Excellent.
So, jetzt müssen wir natürlich...
Jetzt müssen wir natürlich noch dafür sorgen, dass das dynamisch, dynamisch geht, das Icon.
Äh...
Und zwar, wir könnten jetzt...
Letztendlich will ich mir ja eher das CSS angucken und nicht das, das, äh, View-Zeug.
Wir könnten einen Slot machen und dann das Icon aus dem Parent Element da irgendwie rein.
Monkatos-Icon.
Slot?
Ne.
Aber wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Slot?
Und jetzt konnte man doch hier quasi sagen, wenn ich jetzt diese ganze View-JS-Geschichte
noch...
Ja, genau.
Jetzt kann man das hier an der Stelle reinpacken.
Gibt's das nicht noch ein bisschen schöner?
Diese Icons?
Ich hab kein Bock hier immer in SVG reinzukopy-pasten.
Ich mein, das...
Hero-Icons-GitHub.
Gibt's das nicht schon fertig?
So, fertige CSS.
Klassen.
Ich mein, ich könnt auch...
Ich könnt auch, äh...
Einfach die MDE-Icons verwenden, ne?
Das würde auch funktionieren, aber...
Weil das jedes Mal reinkopieren ist doch...
Ja, sowas da.
Genau.
Okay, das ist wieder was anderes.
Okay, weißt du was?
GitHub MDE-Icons.
Fertig.
Äh...
Ja.
Das wird einfach included und gut ist.
Da kenn ich die Icons wenigstens zuvor.
Da...
Ja.
Äh...
GitHub...
Moment, ne, ne.
Warte mal.
Wo gab's denn die Kram zum Download nochmal?
Ich mach das sonst immer wie über die...
Über die CLI.
Da ist das hier.
npm install mde-font.
Gucken wir, ob das funktioniert.
Hier.
Ja, so ging das.
Genau.
Also.
Erstmal das halbe Internet wieder installieren.
Und dann...
Genau.
Import mde-font-css.
Alles klar.
Viele deiner Freunde benutzen den Preisschamp.
Excellent.
Das find ich nice.
Jetzt muss was wie importieren?
Add.
Ne, warte mal.
Wo musste man das jetzt importieren?
In main.
Moment, die Musik ist vorbei.
Ich brauch ein bisschen Mario-Kart-Musik.
Excellent.
Hier.
Import.
Ah, jawoll.
So.
Ja.
Ac.
So.
Ach, jawoll.
Okay.
Wenn ich mich hier verschreibe, dann kann ich das nicht importieren.
Das ist gut.
Da weiß ich wenigstens, dass es funktioniert.
So, also dann bauen wir jetzt mal hier nen Icon rein.
Wie hat man den Kram jetzt nochmal verwendet?
Weil einfach nur mdi irgendwas ging wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oh ne?
Oh, nee, warte mal, wie...
Oh, fuck, wie hat das jetzt nochmal funktioniert?
Ich hab das noch nie außerhalb hiervon...
example?
Please?
...
css will doch einfach nur icons haben npm install ja sowieso schlau bin ich auch schon gewesen und
jetzt example please sagt mir doch einfach wie es funktioniert und das will ich aufmachen dass
der kackmann browser ab wenn ich das aufmachen okay kann jetzt einfach mal gucken dass man
jetzt einfach sagt das will ich nicht dass da will ich schon mdi mdi account warum kann er das
eigen jetzt nicht anzeigen das ist so ein rotz alles kann dazu kompliziert sein alles heute
warum zeigt jetzt nicht einfach ein icon an der stelle ultra komplexer schritt wieder also warum
kann ich jetzt nicht einfach sagen diff klar
mdi alert oder sowas warum ist da hier was das warum ist das hier nicht am start anzeige
ist raus warum geht das warum geht das hier nicht muss ich da vielleicht icon noch dabei machen oder
so was material icons das sind nur wenn man die offiziellen google dinger verwendet glaub das
kann das mal kopieren ich glaube das sind nur für die offiziellen google dinger ja sieht man
mal
die sachen sind nicht so einfach wie sie ja wie sie aussehen dass ich meine es muss ja so easy
sein dass man absolut keine erklärung dazu braucht leon moore das so aber musste einfach mdi davor
schreiben da ist es da haben wir das eigen sehr schön hat jemand eine ahnung wie der parameter
der stuntgranate mw2 heißt möchte die restriktionen na klar wer weiß genau was der amt ist ja ja auch
dann haben wir das icon hier dran und da sieht man auch mal ein bisschen wie das jetzt ausgehen.
Na klar, wer weiß sowas nicht.
Ne, ne, keine Ahnung.
So, jetzt haben wir hier unser Poggers-Icon drin.
Class.
Ähm.
Margin.
Left.
Zwei.
Ne.
Nicht Margin.
Margin Right.
Zwei.
Ha.
Ist doch schick.
Sehr gut.
Ähm.
Home.
Was gibt's da für schöne...
Das ist doch schick.
Das ist doch nice.
Kann man das auch sagen?
H10?
B10?
Oh ne, da blickt er nicht mehr durch.
Jetzt, wenn man das Icon an sich größer macht.
Okay.
Nice.
Das heißt...
Jetzt haben wir eine eigene Button-Component gebaut.
Das finde ich schon mal cool.
Und da können wir jetzt Icons rein-Dingsen.
Okay.
Schön.
So, was können wir noch Interessantes machen damit?
Also...
Okay, hat das Ding einen YouTube-Button?
Twitch?
YouTube?
Gibt's einen Twitch-Icon?
Hey, es gibt ein Twitch-Icon.
Was heißt ein Impressum auf Englisch?
Heißt das nicht Imprint oder sowas?
Impressum Englisch.
Doch, Imprint.
Gibt's nicht.
Äh.
Document.
Wenn man richtig schreiben kann.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Bam.
File.
Document.
Muss ja nicht schön sein, aber...
So.
Excellent.
Naftbar, Alter.
Viel stylischer kann's ja nicht mehr sein.
So.
Und jetzt?
Und super not responsive.
Aber immerhin die Überschrift.
Die Überschrift ist super responsive.
Guckt euch mal an, wie responsive die Überschrift ist.
Massive responsiveness.
Huge.
Huge responsiveness.
Was programmierst du?
Ich guck mir nur Tailwind an.
Ich programmier gar nix.
Ich stell wieder fest, dass ich was Design angeht,
einfach nur sacke, Alter.
Massive Sack.
Was Design angeht, ey.
Okay, also.
Aber ist doch schon mal ne super, super...
Poggers-Nafbar.
Die man manchmal übrigens tracken, droppen kann.
Äh, kann man so selectable oder so ausschalten?
Geht das?
Sele...
Select?
Ah, cool.
Kann ich den Kram hier auch nämlich nicht mehr...
Sinnlos, sinnlos anklicken.
Also, das ist schon mal nice, das gefällt mir, okay.
YouTube Impressum.
Haben die vielleicht...
...legal oder sowas?
Gut, so, dann machen wir jetzt noch...
Okay, also, Nafbar.
Was, was ist denn heutzutage noch in der coolen Nafbar drin?
Ein Settings-Icon, oder?
Settings-Icon ist da noch drin.
Text gibt's net?
Yep.
Cock.
Intonation-Button, genau.
Okay, schick.
Ich mein, der ist ein bisschen fett.
Der ist jetzt, ist jetzt ein bisschen, bisschen, bisschen sehr, ähm...
Sick.
Mach mal W weg, wir machen...
Wie, wie kann ich ne Mindestbreite...
Wobei, ich will gar keine Mindestbreite, ne?
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Das passt schon. Wir machen ne Mindestbreite.
Der Settings-Button muss kleiner sein, auf jeden Fall.
So, dann machen wir nämlich hier einfach so.
Äh, äh...
Icon. Wir bauen jetzt
Beautify nach, im Endeffekt.
Äh, Icon.
So, und dann sagen wir nämlich hier,
wenn...
Wie ging das nochmal? Class...
Wenn...
Wenn Icon...
Dann, ähm...
Moment.
Wenn Icon gesetzt ist, dann
Breite so, und ansonsten
Breite, keine Ahnung, B...
6.
Äh, OKS.
Ach, Moment, umgedreht, umgedreht. Ah.
Wohl weh.
OK.
So, und jetzt kann ich bei meinem Button
hier unten sagen, dass Icon...
Eigentlich Icon...
Ah, go. Funktioniert.
Reicht's auch, wenn ich einfach so
Icon setze? Vielleicht nicht.
Es sieht, es sieht...
beschissen aus.
Es sieht
mega beschissen aus.
Huge, huge.
Ach so, das liegt an meiner Margin.
OK, OK. Hey.
Immerhin, ja.
Massive.
Design-Skills
auf 1.000 hier.
Sieht fast
so gut aus, wie die Magenta-Cloud-Navbar,
ja. OK.
Nice.
Ist das nicht, ist das nicht stylisch, hä?
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Ey, eins kann man zumindest... Es sieht weder nach
Bootstrap aus, noch sieht es
nach, nach, äh, Material-Design
aus. Es sieht nach, nach,
äh, Wobblors-Design
aus. So, und wie
kann ich dem Flex-Zeugs jetzt
sagen, dass der dieses
Icon ans Ende pushen soll?
Das geht doch irgendwie.
Class, Flex...
Ähm...
Item...
Eid...
Nee. Ach, du große Scheiße.
Das ging doch irgendwie.
Flex
Item at end.
Ja, genau.
Hä?
Last.
Nee.
Flex. Wie, wie sage ich dem das jetzt?
Das ist Manjaro.
Tailwind
Flex
Last Item
end.
Items end?
Okay.
Oh, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's big brain.
Align self, flex end?
Ja, du, das gibt's
da aber nicht. End.
Place self end.
Ha! Ha! Nein.
Denied.
Nope.
Ah. Ein.
Ein.
Moment. Weil...
Warte mal. Ist denn jetzt, ist die
jetzt nur bis da, oder geht die über die komplette
Zeile? BG Red.
Die geht über die komplette
Zeile. Okay.
Wie, wie, wie pack ich das Ding jetzt
an, ans Ende?
Ist wieder äußerst, äußerst
komplex.
Justify self end.
Nee. Gut, ähm...
Haben die da,
haben die da irgendein Beispiel für?
Wie ich
davon halt absolut keinen Plan hab, ne?
Justify, ja gut.
So, so schlau war ich auch schon.
Ich will alles,
ich will alles links haben und eins am Ende.
Flex
last item end.
Was eigentlich
margin left auto?
What?
Nee.
Right.
Das muss doch mit flex, das muss doch gehen.
Ich meine,
was ich machen kann ist, äh...
Absolut
und dann right.
Aber das ist glaube ich nicht Sinn und Zweck
der Übung.
Gehen tut's.
Aber sonderlich geil finde ich's, ne?
So.
Ey.
Also Leute, ihr müsst ja schon zugeben, also
das ist eine äußerst
nice, äh,
Navigationsleiste, oder? Also.
Eine, eine der besten.
Definitiv.
Viel nicere Navigationsleiste, oder?
Das sieht so scheiße
aus.
Haha.
Maxus Design
am Start, Alter.
Design
Gott. Ja, sowas will ich haben, genau.
Wow.
Es ist
wie Inline Styles, ja sagen sie ja auch selbst.
Aber wisst ihr,
wisst ihr, was das für einen Vorteil hat?
Wenn ich mich damit ein bisschen beschäftige,
vielleicht werde ich dann ein bisschen besser, was
Design und CSS angeht.
Weil ich hab aktuell halt absolut
kaum Plan davon, ja?
Und
für ein bisschen
Frontend-Stells kann das auf jeden Fall nix schaden.
Margin Top
auch 10, jawoll.
Beste, beste Navbar aller Zeiten.
Vielleicht sollten wir beim Icon
die Höhe auch noch anpassen.
Wobei, die Höhe muss bei allen
gleich sein, sonst sieht's kacke aus.
Oder aber wir machen das noch
einen Ticken, einen Ticken breiter.
Wir sagen sogar 10. Ja, das sieht besser aus.
Oder? Quadratisch.
Oder? So. Das sieht doch tatsächlich
ganz nett aus jetzt.
Machst du meine Hausarbeit in R
mit TensorFlow bis Freitag?
Ich hab noch nicht eine Sache in R gemacht
und mit TensorFlow auch nur sehr am Rande für
meine, äh, äh, Dings hier,
äh, Object-Erkennung.
Okay. Ha. So ist
doch ganz hübsch. So. Also.
Haben wir das erste am Start. Guck mal,
ich find's immer noch geil, wie massive responsive
die Überschrift ist.
Huge responsive ist Überschrift.
Oh, was passiert denn,
wenn es zu klein wird? Hier gar nix.
Dann schreckt's
einfach.
Ich mein, wir könnten ja sogar sagen,
normale Größe ist
4, mittlere Größe
ist 6
und large Größe
ist
Text
8. So.
Passt mal auf. Bam.
Bam. Guck mal hier.
Erste Stufe.
Zweite Stufe. Oh, ist das
huge responsive, ey.
Huge. Ultra
responsive. Okay, was,
was können wir da jetzt noch schönes einbauen?
Button haben wir.
Navigationsleiste haben wir. Ne Karte.
Sowas hier. Oh ja. Oh ja.
Leute. Dings hier.
Ja.
Für den Content. Für den eigentlichen,
für den eigentlichen Content. Content.
So.
So ne Karte. Mit, mit, mit
Schatten und sowas.
Ich hab von R keine Ahnung.
Aber, aber
ich kann Kobol.
Hab ich euch ja letzten Weihnachten bewiesen.
Was für geiler Kobol-Hacker ich bin.
Also, was kann man
da jetzt machen? Also erstmal gibt's
margin. Bisschen Abstand.
Bisschen Abstand. Oh.
Margin.
Margin all 2.
Margin 2.
4.
Okay. Gut. So.
Shadow. Kann man da jetzt,
kann man da jetzt irgendeinen
Also. Full.
Volle Breite.
Mach ich mal den Kram weg.
Volle Höhe.
BG.
Das was man sieht. Okay.
Das ist schon mal keine volle Höhe.
Warum ist die Margin
nicht rechts?
Warum ist die Margin nicht rechts?
Was ist das? Hä?
Ach. Wird das überschrieben, weil ich
volle Breite gesagt hab oder so?
Das ist aber doof.
Ach ne. Moment. Moment.
Der macht das auch so. Ja. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
MX. Ne. Ich will's ja
überall. Ist schon okay.
So. Padding.
Nochmal 4. Padding 4
reicht eigentlich.
Ne. So.
So. Ähm.
Wie krieg ich denn da jetzt?
Wie krieg ich denn da jetzt einen Schatten
dahinter?
Shadow. Hat das jetzt einen Schatten?
Ja. Einen kleinen, oder?
Ja. Das hat einen. Das hat einen Shadow.
Das hat einen Shadow.
Man erkennt das nur kaum.
Color oder sowas.
Sieht kacke aus. Okay. Border.
Border.
Border. Black.
So funktioniert das schon mal nicht.
Das ist die Mario Kart Super Nintendo Ghost Tag.
Okay. Mit Border geht das schon mal nicht.
Border. Border.
Aha. Jetzt ist das was wie Border 2.
Border 3.
Die Musik ist
richtig monkaS. Ja.
Border. Ach hier.
Border.
Was? Rounded.
Oh. Oh. Jetzt wird's. Jetzt wird's zu Big Brain.
Rounded.
Ah ne.
Moment. Das ist Black.
Wie sag ich jetzt die Größe
von dem. Ach so.
Einfach Border 4 zum Beispiel.
Border 2.
Okay. Verstehe.
Wann kommt das Dark Team? Ja. Das muss auch noch sein.
So. Wie macht man so
eine ordentliche Kart, Alter?
Maxors Design am Start wieder.
Also wir brauchen erst mal eine Überschrift.
Also H2.
Class. Text 4.
Aber ich bin ja lernfähig.
Alter. Sieht das beschissen aus hier.
Content.
Egal. Schlecht.
So. Wie krieg ich denn da jetzt.
Wie sieht eine schöne
Content Dings aus?
Wie sieht denn sowas aus?
Wie sieht denn die Beautify
Kart aus? Die sieht doch ganz hübsch
aus. So.
Im Prinzip besteht diese Karte nur
aus
einem Schatten dahinter.
Sonst nix.
Titel. Titel. Text.
Okay. Button. Button brauchen wir noch.
Big Brain Buttons brauchen wir noch.
Oh.
Achso. Das ist der falsche Button, den ich copy pasted hab.
Zwei Buttons brauchen wir noch. Genau.
Class.
Äh. Margin.
Right 2. Okay.
Aber kein Impressum. Kein Impressum.
Sondern Text. Äh. Keine Ahnung.
Ähm. Save.
Und
Cancel.
Mir fällt jetzt da grad nix anderes ein
zu. So.
Ähm. Disc heißt
das Ding.
Save. Äh.
Das ist Visual Studio Code.
Also. Welche Software benutzt du?
Genau. Das ist Visual Studio Code.
Allerdings.
Je nachdem. Für R habe ich keine Ahnung.
Also ich verwende Rider.
Ich verwende Rider.
Für C-Sharp Backend Gedöns.
Und Visual Studio Code für Frontend
Kram.
Content Save. Okay.
Das ist das Ding.
Gibt es auch ein Material Design Icon
Extension?
Äh.
Material Design Icon
via Code IntelliSense.
Jetzt bestimmt.
Ah. Guck mal da.
Excellent.
Das da.
Material Design Icons IntelliSense.
Da kann ich dann quasi schreiben MDI.
Ey. Das ist praktisch.
Das brauchen wir.
Install. Bam.
Exquisite.
Jaja. Das Beautiful.
Das kann. Das weiß ich.
So. Und jetzt. Äh.
MDI.
Ach. Hier. Guck mal. Der kann das ja. Das ist ja cool.
Guck mal. Jetzt zeigt er auch sogar das
Icon hier als Vorschau an. Das ist cool.
Also MDI.
Und jetzt kann ich sowas wie Save.
Das ist tatsächlich nice. Okay. Das gefällt mir.
Das hat was.
Moin. Aber das ist cool.
So. Jetzt müssen wir natürlich dem Button
noch irgendwie eine andere Background Color
beibringen können. Ne?
Wie können wir unseren Button Client, den
Big Brain Button, dem müssen wir jetzt noch andere
Background Color beibringen können.
So.
Also. Cancel. Cancel ist.
Ich glaub das hieß einfach Cancel.
Genau.
Sieht aber richtig dumm aus.
Das heißt einfach nur Cancel. Genau.
Exquisite.
Das Icon kommt auch weg.
Ästlich auch. Sehr schön.
So. Wie könnte man jetzt so diese
Kart schick machen?
Also die haben im Prinzip ja nichts anderes als
einen Titel.
Titel habe ich auch.
Subtitle brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Wie macht man
den Text überhaupt? Grau.
Haben wir P.
Oh Leute. Wir brauchen
den Lorem Ipsum Generator.
Ganz wichtig.
Gibt es doch bestimmt ja.
Ja genau. Exquisite.
Das ist ganz ganz
Muss.
Bacon. Bacon. Bacon Ipsum. Okay.
Gibt es das auch?
Kann der das
so schon?
Ach tatsächlich. Guck mal da.
Muss man gar nichts mehr selbst machen.
Braucht man gar keine Extension für.
Kannst du nicht
mit der Musik konsumieren? Klar.
Das ist ultra ultra nice
entspannende Musik. Also.
Content.
Ich mein. Hey. Man muss mal sagen.
Die Seite sieht jetzt nicht wirklich
wahnsinnig schön aus.
Aber die sieht auch nicht ultra hässlich aus.
Oder?
Ich mein. Es gibt
doch durchaus schlimmeres.
So.
Funktionabel.
Okay.
Wie können wir denn jetzt
da irgendwie einen ordentlichen
Schatten hin machen? Tailwind.
Shadow.
Das ist nicht bloated.
Genau. So sieht es aus. Box Shadow.
Ja habe ich doch. Shadow. Shadow MD.
Ja aber die Color vom Shadow brauchen wir
noch. Okay. Okay.
Shadow.
Shadow Inner.
Erkenne ich überhaupt nicht. Shadow.
Also man erkennt ein bisschen. Aber.
Es ist doch kaum. Kaum.
Das liegt
an meinem Hintergrund wahrscheinlich.
Ah doch. Jetzt erkennt man es.
Aber das liegt an meinem Hintergrund, dass man das nicht so richtig
erkennt.
Border kleiner. Ne ne. Man erkennt schon.
Border braucht man übrigens. Border brauchen wir übrigens gar nicht.
Aber
Grounded darf es sein. Das ist durchaus
in Ordnung.
Doch doch. Guck mal. Jetzt. Jetzt. Jetzt.
Jetzt steht das so richtig raus. Wir müssen jetzt nur noch
die gesamte Seite einfach ein bisschen.
BG.
Black. Ne BG.
Grey. Grey.
Ich glaub das geht nicht.
An der Stelle.
Muss ich da nen Diff drum rum machen. Komplett.
4 Class.
BG.
Öh. Öh.
Öh.
Kumuweide. Ja.
Geh fort.
Ich glaub da müssen wir Main.
Moment. Wo ist denn das
Body Element drinne?
Warte. Warte. Warte. Wo haben sie das versteckt?
Body. Body. Hier Index. Da ist es wahrscheinlich.
Ja. Yes. Moment.
Warum ist der Hintergrund
jetzt auch?
Ach. Weil sich das vererbt.
Na. No rules.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Oh.
Das vererbt sich der Hintergrund. Okay.
Also brauchen wir dann hier
sowas wie.
Einfach BG.
B. BG.
White.
Grey.
Das sieht jetzt gar nicht so kacke aus.
Das kann man sogar
halbwegs lassen.
Äh.
B2. Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Massive Brain
Subscription. Hier wieder.
Genau. Ich mach das
E-Mail Design neu. Easy.
So. Wir machen jetzt zwischen
NAV Bar und unten.
Öh. Margin. Bottom. Machen wir nur ein bisschen Platz.
Ey.
Also ich muss sagen.
Für das das ich so ultra sacke.
Das. Das. Das sieht
besser aus als ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Ja.
So. Jetzt müssen wir noch die Buttons
irgendwie ein bisschen anpassen.
Und zwar.
Also. Ich kopier
jetzt Beautify einfach mal.
So. Icon haben wir. Ansonsten haben wir
noch zur Auswahl. Ähm.
Das können wir noch machen. Was. Was ist
das. Was. Was gibt es genau für ein
Button Typ. Äh. Text.
Ne. Nicht Text. Ähm.
Irgendwie so Transparent oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung. Off.
Weiß nicht
wie ich es nennen soll. Dass ich den
Hintergrund weg mache.
Sieht aus wie ein Cookie Banner. Ja.
Tatsächlich.
Oder. Oder. Oder.
Weil. Weil was jetzt ganz cool
wäre. Wenn ich jetzt noch einen Button hätte.
Wo einfach.
Wo einfach nur ein Text steht.
So für Cancel.
Also. Also.
Ich kopier das mal. Ich zeige euch mal was ich meine.
Das wir jetzt einfach
sowas hier haben. Äh.
Naja. Das da da
steht Cancel.
Und
allerdings komplett
ohne Background.
Oh.
Fuck. Dann erkennt man es ja gar nicht mehr.
Dann muss man die. Die Schrift.
Sowas hier.
Warte mal. Ne. Warte mal. Die Schrift
machen wir jetzt einfach so. Ha.
Die Idee.
Leute. Die Idee.
Das. Das gefällt mir.
Das ist nice. Pock.
Das suckt aber.
Active Orbeck.
Das gefällt mir. Das ist nice.
Hä. Da hast du den Save Button.
Da hast du den Save Button und den Cancel Button.
Das machen die beispielsweise
bei Digital Ocean und
bei äh. Keine Ahnung.
Bei vielen Seiten machen die das so.
Das der. Der wichtige Button ist ein Button.
Und der Cancel Button ist so.
Ist so. So da.
Ja. Das finde ich eigentlich gut.
Ist halt nicht so auffällig.
Springt nicht so. Springt nicht so
sehr ins Auge. Okay.
Nice. Ist es jetzt
auch responsive?
Äh. Ja.
So. So ein bisschen.
Bis auf die Navigationsleiste.
Die ist nicht wirklich responsive.
Aber da bin ich
zu dumm. Ich weiß nicht wie ich die. Wie ich die besser
responsive machen soll.
Weil irgendwo müssen die Texte ja hin.
Common Sense sagt er findet das
Design schön und clean. Ich würde es
noch nicht mal so weit gehen und Design nennen.
Ich hab
halt irgendwas zusammen gebastelt. Okay.
Nice. Aber.
Es ist auf jeden Fall
besser als äh.
Die nächste Bootstrap Seite.
Lass sie untereinander rutschen.
Ja da weiß ich erstens nicht
wie es geht. Und zweitens glaube ich sieht das so
unkontrolliert ziemlich doof aus.
Eigentlich müsste die Navigationsleiste.
Oh. Leute.
Ich hab die Big Brain
Idee ever.
Wir machen den Text
weg. Wir machen den Text
weg wenn es einfach zu klein wird.
Wir machen nur noch die Icons.
Das ist die Idee.
Es ist nur noch die Frage wie wir das
machen. Also sprich wenn es zu
klein wird. Dann machen wir nur noch
die Icons in den Button.
Big Brain. Ja. Poggers.
So machen wir das.
Aber ich weiß nicht wie ich das mache.
Okay. Warte mal.
Ähm.
Okay.
Okay. Big Brain Time.
Nutzt du Tailwind fürs nächste Projekt?
Vielleicht. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich wollte es mir einfach machen.
Okay. Okay. Moment.
Ich erkenne ja wieder nichts, weil ich hier
nichts line-pranken kann.
Also. Also. Das ist alles okay.
Wir müssen jetzt.
Ne. Das ist easy.
Das ist easy. Einfach
gucken. Hier.
Diff. Das ist easy as fuck
ist das Leute. Easy
as fuck. Passt mal auf. Passt mal auf.
Äh. Wenn es.
Wenn es.
Small ist.
Class. Wenn es
small ist. Dann.
Display.
Äh. Oder non.
Ähm.
Wie mach ich denn das weg?
Tailwind. Display non.
Ne. Burger Menü bin ich
zu dumm für. Block.
Hidden. Hidden. Hidden ist es.
Hidden. Hä?
Sollte das nicht genau umgedreht
sein? Gott.
Hä?
Gott. Hä?
Versteht das irgendjemand?
Wenn es small ist.
Ist es da?
Hä? Ja. Ist doch. Ist doch
okay. Aber sollte es
normalerweise nicht angezeigt werden?
So ganz verstanden habe ich es
immer noch nicht.
Aber prinzipiell ist es so richtig.
So. Und jetzt muss ich einfach nur
noch sagen, dass die
Breite.
Achso.
Bei SM wird dann das dahinter
ausgelöst. Ja. Aber es ist die
default hidden.
Es ist default hidden. Aber
default ist es da.
Obwohl es
default hidden sein müsste. Weil das hier ist ja nicht
SM. Oder bedeutet das
nicht bei der
kleiner, sondern größer SM.
Dann würde das
nämlich Sinn. Ist das hier kein kleiner
sondern impliziert einen größer
als. Achso.
Ah. Verstehe.
Verstehe.
Mobile first. Excellent.
So. Jetzt ist natürlich die große
Preisfrage. Wie kriege ich es jetzt
gebacken, dass
die Breite angepasst
wird?
Also sage ich SM.
Moment. SM.
Breite.
Null.
Okay.
Oh.
MonkaS.
Okay. Das funktioniert schon mal.
Wenn es klein
ist, dann ist nur.
Also wenn es größer ist. Wenn es größer ist
will ich 32 haben.
Okay. Das passt.
Aber. Aber nicht
bei Icon. Warum überschreibt
er das jetzt nicht?
Das ist nicht Bootstrap. Nein. Das ist
eigene Konstruktion.
Der Save Button ist was eigenes.
Ja. Also prinzipiell.
Leute. Ich bin
ultra verwirrt. Was mache ich hier überhaupt?
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Ah.
Okay. Scheiß mal
auf das Icon erstmal.
Das funktioniert
ja fast schon.
Fast.
Wie sage ich ihm denn dann
die Größe für SM?
Also das ist alles
über SM. Und dann sage ich
ihm Default. Default ist 10.
Ah.
Okay. Aber das sieht
das sieht ziemlich
crappy aus.
Okay. Ich muss auf jeden Fall
dieses Margin Gedöns hier rausnehmen.
Sonst sackt das.
Jetzt funktioniert das
nicht. Okay.
Das sieht doch schon mal besser aus.
Guck dir mal. Guck dir mal. Fast.
Fast. Guck mal.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Es geht nicht. Es geht in die richtige
Richtung. Ja.
Es geht in die richtige Richtung.
Das hier hinten stimmt nicht. Aber
das ist okay.
Es ist fast schon mal fast schon fast
gut. Ja.
Aber die Idee funktioniert schon mal.
Hast du schon einen Friseur Termin?
Ne. Habe ich noch nicht. Aber es wird mal wieder
Zeit. Aber es wird echt mal
wieder Zeit. By the way
meine Buttons sind natürlich kaputt.
Weil das sich jetzt nur auf die Navbar
Icons bezieht. Nicht auf den Button da unten.
Deswegen mache ich den Button da unten
mal kurz da raus.
Mach das jetzt einfach weg. Ich will jetzt die Navbar ordentlich
hinkriegen. So.
Wie kriege ich das gebutton
dass der
das ist ja alles so schön
und gut. Aber ich will
das das Icon
immer überschreibt das ganze.
Also wenn ein
Icon gesetzt ist.
Wie kann ich ihm jetzt sagen
dass das Vorrang hat vor dem.
Okay das ist. Das ist glaube
ich jetzt nicht so easy.
SMW10
beim Icon.
Stimmt.
Stimmt. Man kann.
Das bringt nichts. Wenn ich das beim
Icon mache, bringt nichts. Dann ist der Button
ja trotzdem so breit.
Ich muss... Moment. Ich weiß, was ich
machen muss. Warte mal. Das ist Schwachsinn,
was ich hier gemacht habe.
Das stimmt nicht, was ich hier gemacht habe. So muss das sein.
Guck, jetzt bleibt es nämlich
immer gleich groß.
Und
Default ist es W10.
Ha! Excellent!
Guckt euch das an!
Massive
Responsiveness hier.
Massive Responsiveness.
UI-Guru. Ich mache
mein Udemy und
sonst was
Kurs gibt es morgen.
Aber das ist nice.
Das ist cool. Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
Okay, das
hier sieht sackig aus. Aber ganz ehrlich,
wer den Kram so klein macht, hat echt gelitten.
Guck mal, sogar...
Seht ihr, wie massive responsive
die Überschrift ist hier schon?
Kekweight. Kekweight. Kekweight.
Kekweight. Großer. Kekweight. Fett.
Poggers, Alter.
Massive.
Was gibt es eigentlich noch für Breakpoints?
Tailwind. Breakpoints.
Vielleicht ist ja SM gar nicht so das passende.
Breakpoints. Also.
SM, MD. Vielleicht sollte ich es besser auch
ab MD machen.
Äh, nicht. Quatsch, Quatsch. Nicht ab MD.
Gibt es noch was kleineres?
Ne, SM ist das kleinste. Alles klar.
Sind zwar ein bisschen viel Platz, aber
was willst du machen?
Hat der immer eine bessere Idee,
wenn man das ein bisschen kleiner hinkriegt?
Aber das ist okay, weil das könnte...
Wobei, ne, das bringt gar nichts.
Guck mal, hier wird es anstoßen.
Hier wird es anstoßen. Das musst du ja.
Das musst du ja machen. Cool.
Ich meine, man könnte die Buttons
ein bisschen größer machen.
Ah, Moment. Jetzt ist natürlich das andere auch...
Fuck. By the way, warum
hat es das so nicht funktioniert?
Ach so. Warte, weil ich es so machen muss.
Aha.
Exquisite.
So.
Also es ist 10, wenn es ein Icon ist.
Oder es ist, sagen wir mal,
14?
Ja, cool. Nice.
Oh, das ist schick.
Guck mal, jetzt sind nämlich die Icons ein bisschen
größer. Und man könnte die Icons...
Leute, jetzt noch massive
brain-Idee. Wir machen die
Icons größer, wenn es minimiert.
Wenn das so...
Jetzt machen wir die Icons noch größer, weil das ist ja
der Text weg.
Magst du Web-App,
Frameworks und CSS? Moment, Moment.
Ich war gerade so vertieft in meine
Kreation.
Es gibt für Vue
eine Bootstrap-Component-Library.
Ich glaube, das hier.
Das ist quasi
Vue-Components im Bootstrap-Style.
Das ist dann
quasi sowas wie Vuetify, nur im
Bootstrap-Look.
Gibt ja noch mehr. Gibt ja noch
Bulma und Bufi, Büfi,
Buefi oder wie man das ausspricht.
Und es gibt noch
Quasar und es gibt ja
zig, zig, zig Dinger,
die irgendwelche CSS-Sachen
nehmen und daraus Vue-Components bauen.
Im Prinzip ist es ja das Gleiche, was
ich hier auch mache. Ich habe hier so
ein komisches Button-Component gebastelt
mit Tailwind-Styling.
Oh, das finde ich nice.
Guck mal, guck mal wie das...
Excellent.
Boah, wie responsive es ist
hier. Massive responsive.
Ich freue mich gerade richtig.
Man kann mich auch mit einfachen Sachen
erfreuen. So, und jetzt
noch Icons größer machen.
Und jetzt noch Icons
größer machen. Wie machen wir Icons größer,
wenn das klein ist?
Da müssen wir doch eigentlich nur...
Die Icons sind ja im Endeffekt da.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen doof.
Kann man die Icons
so vielleicht...
Welch? Das ist I3-WM.
Moment...
Wie kriege ich...
Ich muss das mal kurz mit Inline-CSS probieren,
ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Font-Size...
Nice, okay, das wird das machen.
Also sage ich dann jetzt
Class...
Font...
Nee, Text war es.
Text...
XL...
Pockers...
So, und das sagen wir nur...
Warte mal, warte mal.
Es ist... Moment, Moment.
Wir wollen defaultmäßig Text
LG
oder so haben.
Dass es gut aligned aussieht.
Text MD.
Text M gibt es noch.
SM Base wollen wir nochmal haben.
Das sieht das
ohne was auch so aus.
So, Text Base
und dann, wenn das...
Nee, Moment.
Umgedreht, umgedreht.
Das...
Das Invert im Kopf muss ich noch...
Muss ich noch...
Guck mal, die Icons
werden größer.
Zack.
Excellent. Exquisite.
Das ist doch schick.
Guckst du dir sonst nur die Doku...
Ich guck mir gar nichts an.
Ich hab das zum ersten Mal heute verwendet.
Und ja, ich hab im Prinzip nur da reingeguckt
und ein bisschen getting started.
Man merkt doch, ich hab auch keinen Plan.
Guck mal, wie die Unterschiede...
Sobald das hier verschwindet
von großer
Navbar zu klein,
werden die Buttons größer und die Icons größer.
So ist das doch sehr schick.
Sehr, sehr schick.
Excellent, excellent.
By the way, die Dinger sind gar nicht richtig aligned.
Ne?
Ich glaub einfach nur das Twitch-Icon
suckt.
Nur das Twitch-Icon ist kacke.
Guck mal.
Der Rest ist gut aligned.
Das Twitch-Icon suckt.
Das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir.
So, wie krieg ich da jetzt noch
einen Margin rein zwischen
den Text und dem Icon?
Margin
Right 2.
Moment. Ah, nee, nee, nee.
SSM.
Yes, yes, exquisite.
Ich weiß...
Leute, ich bin grad ein bisschen am durchdrehen.
Ich glaub, man merkt's. Aber ich bin echt begeistert davon,
wie gut das funktioniert.
Zu viel Margin findste?
Margin 1.
Schau, was ist besser? 1 Margin oder 2 Margin?
Oder vielleicht sogar
3 Margin oder 4 Margin?
1?
1? Ernsthaft?
Ich persönlich find 2 schicker, aber...
Chat, Chat
meint 1. 5, ja, 5 ist excellent.
Aber warum nicht gleich 16?
Okay, 1. Margin 1.
Ja.
Oh, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Ah.
Große dicke Finger.
Moment, jetzt stimmt mein...
Fuck. Jetzt stimmt das Icon nicht mehr.
Kann ich das jetzt irgendwie noch
geschickt umschiffen?
Margin
nur auf Text anwenden?
Ja.
Das können wir machen, das ist eine gute Idee.
Also, dass wir quasi sagen, hier
Margin left.
Aber so ganz stimmt das immer noch nicht.
Achso, nein, der weiß ja nicht,
der weiß ja nicht, dass wir den Text hier ausblenden.
Der macht die...
Der blendet das nicht mit aus.
Der ist da zu nubig für.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht,
wenn's ausgeblendet ist, ist Margin auch weg,
aber okay. Ist es anscheinend
nicht.
Hidden is display none.
Sagen die zumindest.
Haben die gesagt?
Hidden display none.
Steht da.
Dass ich das translate zu.
Kann man ja mal gucken.
Man sieht äußerst viel jetzt.
Richtig, richtig
massive viel zu sehen hier.
Ich bin doch gar nicht dabei.
Moment. Wait a minute.
Das funktioniert ja auch mit dem Hidden.
Wenn es Hidden ist, dann geht das weg.
Ähm.
Nee, nee, das stimmt schon.
Aber das Problem ist, dass es ja normalerweise,
wenn es kleiner wird, auch keinen Text hat.
Das heißt, ich müsste hier eigentlich noch
Big Brain Abfrage reinmachen.
Ob da, ob da, ähm.
Quasi.
Ob das ein Icon only ist.
Also im Prinzip
müsste man jetzt nochmal
sowas hier machen.
Fällt mir jetzt grad nichts anderes ein.
Icon. Wenn Icon,
dann äh.
Nix.
Und ansonsten.
Was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen? Achso.
Und ansonsten SM
margin left
eins.
Guckt, jetzt passt es.
Zwar nicht schön, aber funktioniert.
So.
Excellent, excellent.
So, was könnte man noch, was könnte man
noch designen? Wo wir hier grad
im Design-God-Modus sind.
How if Text?
Nee, Text ist
ja immer gesetzt. Der blendet Text nur dynamisch
aus, je nachdem wie breit
das ist. Also in Text, hier
steht immer was drin. Dark Mode.
Boah, da bin ich zu low brain, glaub ich.
Für Tailwind, Dark Mode.
Okay, das probieren wir jetzt noch aus.
Dark Mode.
Bottom Navigation.
So ein Futter, Futter,
Futter, Futter, wie heißt
denn das überhaupt? Futter?
Futter?
Futter? Wie spricht
man das richtig aus?
Futter.
Pronounciation.
Futu.
Ah, Moment, ich hab hier
keinen Sound.
Achtung. Futter.
Futter.
American Kokona?
Futter. Futter.
Futter, perfekt.
Futter.
Futter gefällt mir auch am besten.
Kokona Style, Alter.
Beste. Futter.
Futter. Futter.
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt ein Futter.
Machen wir jetzt.
Ich bin begeistert über meine responsive
Skills hier.
Achso, Moment, hier die Icons unten sehen noch ziemlich
sackig aus, ne?
Ich hab jetzt, oh fuck, ich hab jetzt keinen Bock
meinen Button noch anzupassen, dass ich ihn
Ja, der Button geht jetzt natürlich nicht.
Weil der Button denkt,
er ist in der NAV-Bar.
Okay, aber das, das, das können wir,
das können wir ändern.
Da machen wir jetzt hier noch so, noch
ein Prop.
Keine Ahnung, wie nenn ich das denn?
NAV?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Static, wobei Static ist schon doppelt
belegt, ne? Wenn Static
gesetzt ist,
Static,
wenn Static gesetzt ist, dann
macht er diesen ganzen Krempel nicht.
Dieser ganze
responsive Mist
macht er dann einfach nicht.
So, also sprich, wo ist hier unser responsive
responsive Kram?
Dann mal durch. Ah ne, da muss ich hier noch ein
if ins if machen.
No, no, no, no, no.
Das, oh ne, ne, ne, ne,
das mach ich nicht.
Da müsste ich hier noch ein if reinbauen. Alter.
Also
sprich, Moment mal, mal gucken ob wir das
inline hinkriegen. Wartet mal.
Static?
Oh ne, das funktioniert
gar nicht, oder? Ah, das ist
preserved. Okay.
Lull, heißt es einfach nur dann.
Lull.
Okay, noch funktioniert alles?
Ha, fast.
Fast. Fast.
Okay, das ist mega hässlich gerade, aber
prinzipiell
funktioniert es mal.
Oh, ist das eklig.
Hahaha.
Keck wait. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob ich jetzt überhaupt was machen muss.
Aber, Lull.
Okay, das ist massive abartig.
Ne, Moment, was hab ich da jetzt gemacht?
Keck wait.
Ah.
Ich blick da mal durch, Leute.
Massive clean code.
Also, wenn das nicht clean code ist, Leute, dann weiß ich auch nicht,
was das hier sein... Achso, das liegt an dem
hinten. An dem hinten
liegt das. Also sprich,
eigentlich müsste ich jetzt sagen, ähm,
äh, kann ich sowas doppelt hier machen?
Oder?
Da müsste ich jetzt, da müsste ich
jetzt, also quasi,
sowas hier?
Oh, ne,
da kenne ich die Syntax nicht für.
Wie ist denn die richtige Syntax?
Äh...
Oh, fuck, das kriege ich, das weiß ich,
das kriege ich aus dem Kopf noch mal hin.
Wie ist denn die richtige Syntax, für das ich
das nur mache, wenn das true ist?
Irgendwie klammern oder so?
War das irgendwas mit Klammern drumherum?
Ne.
View
style...
Hier, das da, das da meine ich.
Das, das da meine ich, also...
Ich war ja fast
richtig, fast richtig.
Äh, Moment. Ah.
Ah, ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Okay, ähm, äh, wie?
Class? Class?
Das da?
Das muss man bestimmt quoten, dass das funktioniert.
Und jetzt...
Not icon.
Ne.
Ne, ne, das funktioniert schon.
Not icon?
Ah, yes.
Sehr gut, okay.
Okay, das funzt.
So, Moment, jetzt habe ich schon ganz vergessen, was ich
machen wollte.
Ich wollte den Save-Button safen.
Ähm...
So,
okay, wie könnte man das jetzt machen?
Der Save-Button soll da bleiben,
wenn lull gesetzt ist.
Also sprich,
wenn...
Kann man das jetzt...
Wie macht man da mehrere Sachen?
Mit Komma?
Wenn not lull?
Wenn, wenn lull?
Äh...
Wait a minute.
Wird das jetzt?
Also, eins von beiden müsste ja
funktionieren jetzt.
Kann man das nicht so hintereinander schreiben?
Ich bin da zu blöd für.
Da muss doch hidden mit rein.
Echt jetzt?
Hinten ist doch eigentlich default dann.
Ach ne, Moment, sonst ist es immer hidden.
Sehr gut.
Exquisite, so ist das.
Es ist massive clean code.
Clean coders hassen diesen Trick.
Aber es funktioniert.
Warum ist jetzt eigentlich das da und das da
nicht mehr auf der gleichen Höhe?
Warum ist das jetzt da unten
und das nicht?
Da ist ja nichts drin.
Also, jetzt wollen wir noch
ein Footer machen.
Bist du jetzt
echt Partner von Gamers Only?
Und was?
Was zum Teufel ist das überhaupt?
Ich kenn auch
Gamers Only AT
oder so.
Das war so ein
österreicher Shop.
Was ist denn das?
Energy Drink, ne.
Wie kommst du da drauf, dass ich Partner von denen
bin ich würde ich würde ich ohne scheiß ich lasse mich sofort partnern wenn es
genug geld gibt es wird es egal ob monster ob die fuel ob obdings hier ist
mir wurde gibt man ich partner ist du hast das auf twitter gelesen schickt man
den link also twitter also wenn ich partner wäre dann hätte ich das selbst
selbst getweetet ganz von ausgehen sie schickt man den link wo das irgendjemand
erzählt habe dass ich gamers only partner wer nicht dass sie nicht dass
sie in den müll schreiben oder so aber mal ganz davon abgesehen was ich
interessiere doch 2021 gar kein mehr warum sollte irgendwie ein komisches
zeug verbreiten ich habe letztens gesehen energy trinkt
als pillen form ist das glaube ich booster fürs gehirn da kannst du dir
koffein tabletten einschmeißen also weiß ich nicht
ernsthaft
ich will wir können ich könnte gamer gamer boy wobei boy passt nicht gamer
mann badewasser verkaufen gamer boomer badewasser wie wäre das wäre doch mal
ich mag glück oder warum ist das zeug nicht allein
bei the way juckt mich jetzt nicht warum es nicht allein das bleibt jetzt einfach
so aber warum ist das nicht allein ach so warum ist das jetzt warum ist das so
weit unten
und nicht in der mit aber irgendwie aber eine ahnung ach so ach so wie in diesem
komischen alten schritt den ich da oben kopiert habe ist das das muss ja kann
ja alles weg warum ist das jetzt nicht in der mit center
warum ist das jetzt jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt safe cancel warum
ist das cancel unten und nicht in der mitte
k somebody
ok
ich habe jetzt
kein km
ok
dass sowas
kl hast du endlich
versteht
das ganze
uz
warum ist ein bild in der mitte warum ist es mit einem und warum ist das
kennst du alleine nicht in der mitte ich bin hoch gerade schön ich werde ich
werde frontend kram liefern stehen er hat eine andere höhe und der safe
partner ok also meinst du ich muss dem ding auch noch ich bin das heißt ich
muss dem ding auch eine höhe geben oder was
wobei warum flex ich das überhaupt gibt keinen sinn
das margin vom safe was hat es mit dem inhalt davon moment das verstehe ich
jetzt nicht ach so weil es im martin top hat ja klar
keck ich dachte das ist es ist es aber nicht
und da hätte ich auch gedacht dass das ist es ist es nicht
ja
ja okay ich habe keine ahnung warum das doch nicht mal kurz licht anmachen hier
wird es ein bisschen dunkel also dass das das ja inspekten
ah guck mal guck mal das ding ist verschoben warum warum das denn warum
ist das verschoben man hat einfach ein break jetzt ist wieder grad warum ist
das so verschoben guckt mal
bg vertical allein top was passt mal auf was ich verstehe es wieder nicht wo kommt
das her warum sind die dinger nicht gleich hoch wartet mal wenn ich die
dinger nebeneinander kopiert ist es dann wenigstens gleich okay das ist klar hat
der moment
jetzt bin ich äußerst äußerst verwirrt äußerst verwirrt bin ich jetzt wisst
ihr was wir machen
wir geben dem einfach okay wenn wir wenn jetzt mache ich das ist nicht null
sondern das sorgt dafür dass es irgendwie immer voll ist ist voll
anstatt null ist nichts anderes ein so und jetzt bauen
noch was und das ist das dann wie es cancel das ksi cancel button ist und
dann
Wie kompliziert man so einen Button machen kann.
Ich sag ja, Clean Coders hassen diesen Trick.
So, und das ist jetzt ein Cancel Button.
Das heißt, sobald Cancel gesetzt ist,
dann wird einfach der Hintergrund ausgeblendet.
Easy.
Also sprich...
Oh, OKS.
Kriege ich jetzt den Hintergrund ausgeblendet, wenn...
Hier.
Dann muss ich das aber so machen.
Und nicht so.
Oh, das ist eh schöner.
OK, ähm...
Wie kriege ich das jetzt dahin übersetzt?
Also, wenn...
Also, wenn Icon...
Wenn Icon, dann...
Wenn Icon, dann will ich W10 haben.
Aber damit kriege ich kein Ls hin.
Ah, ah, Brain.
Brain, zu klein dafür.
Mein Brain ist zu small.
Mein Brain ist...
Zu small dafür.
Ui.
Was will...
Ich will gar nichts programmieren, Großart.
Ich lasse das jetzt so.
Das war nicht schön, aber das hat funktioniert.
Easy.
So.
OK, ähm...
Ich kann da doch jetzt nicht noch einen If reinmachen.
Jetzt irgendwann ist doch mal gut.
Da...
Das...
Das übersteigt jetzt meine Big Brain-Fähigkeiten, ne?
Wie ich das...
Wie kriege ich das jetzt gescheit hin?
Ich will jetzt...
Ich will jetzt den Hintergrund ausblenden.
Ich meine, ich könnte den ganzen...
Easy.
Pass...
Pass mal auf.
Big...
Big Brain.
Oh.
Ah, yes.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache, aber okay.
Bam.
Ah, nee, Moment.
Was...
Was brauchen wir für...
Font.
Ah, yes.
Sehr gut.
Perfekt.
Es ist zwar...
Absolut nicht schön.
Aber es wird...
Okay, same.
Cancel.
Sehr gut.
Alles klar.
So.
Ist das nicht nice, Leute?
Exquisite.
So.
Was wollten wir jetzt...
Was wollten wir jetzt als nächstes machen?
Futter.
Ein Futter wollten wir noch programmieren.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie es die Engländer aussprechen.
Moment.
Futter.
Wie?
Futter?
Ein F...
Wie Vogel?
Futter?
Dann ist die Kokona-Variante besser.
Futter.
Futter wie Pepo-Fett-Futter.
Ja.
So, und passt mal jetzt auf.
Wenn ich jetzt noch sagen könnte, dass wir den Button, den Hintergrund grün machen,
dann würde ich einfach noch einen If hinzufügen und schon ist die Button-Component auf einmal
30 Seiten lang.
Ja, Handy-Aufladestation.
Ganz schlecht.
Hatschi-Bait.
So.
Ähm.
Wobei.
Heißt das jetzt, du musst mir das wirklich donaten?
Sonst die...
Sonst die Abmahnung raus.
PayPal-Anzeige.
Wenn es nicht eintrifft bis morgen.
Genau.
Donate oder Anzeige.
Oih.
So, also, nen Futter, nen Futter wollten wir bauen.
Okay, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Also, ich habe eine Idee, wie wir das machen.
Und zwar, wir haben jetzt hier, wir haben jetzt eine Überschrift, wir haben so eine komische
Navbar und wir haben einen Setting-Button, der nichts macht, aber der ist da.
Insolvenz.
Ja, man muss Prioritäten setzen.
Ich finde, Donation geht vor Insolvenz.
Weil, was interessiert mich, ob du nach der Donation Insolvenz gehst.
So, also, hier machen wir jetzt ein Futter.
If.
Futter.
Nee, nee, nee, da, da nicht.
Also, da sagen wir jetzt, Klaas, kann man halt so absolut sagen, dass der unten ist?
Absolut bottom.
Null.
Bam, da unten ist er.
Guck, da, wie es für den Futter sich gehört.
Futter ist am Start.
Der Futter.
Nee, äh, vier.
So.
Okay.
Was kriegt denn der für einen Background?
Was ist ein guter Futter-Background?
Guck mal hier, wie massive responsive.
Oh, der Futter.
Der Futter.
Der, der, der, der Futtert sich da rein.
Hellgrau.
Noch helleres Grau.
100?
Ja gut, dann, dann so wie die hier, oder?
Oder, oh Mann.
Mann.
Äh.
Wait.
Ach so.
Die, die Breite ist nicht da.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Äh.
Rounded full.
Ich mach einfach mal kurz das gleiche wie da.
Ja.
Ähm.
Oh, wow.
Excellent.
So, so lassen wir es, oder?
Ist, ist eigentlich, ist eigentlich mal was, mal was Eigenes, ja?
Wofür ist die Seite?
Für nichts, dass ich, dass ich mir Tailwind angucken kann.
Ah, warum?
Ah, wahrscheinlich, weil es Absolut ist.
Oh, Moment.
Ich hab das Diff im Diff drinne.
Ich kack Noob.
Warum, warum ist hier überhaupt ein Diff übrig?
Das Diff hat doch hier überhaupt nichts zu, Moment.
Das Diff, Moment, das Diff gehört zu dem Diff, äh, mein Fuller muss dahin.
Warum wird das klein bei Absolut?
Kann ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt sagen, äh, full?
Äh.
Mon, Mon, Monka.
Ihh.
Was wird das?
Ich lern Tailwind CSS gerade.
Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
Wie krieg ich den jetzt dazu, dass der die komplette Breite frisst?
Okay.
Tailwind, Futter, Absolut.
Stackoverflow, Beste.
Was?
Ah, es gibt ne extra Futter-Component.
Ne, äh, es gibt mittlerweile echt ne Futter, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh,
äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Äh.
Tech
Soft
Okay, aber wirklich was machen
Aber, aber wirklich was machen
Tut er nicht, oder?
So you play
Aha
H-Screen
Das ist die Höhe, oder?
Was macht H-Screen?
Wow, excellent
With screen
Ja, aber das ist zu fett
MB-Auto
Hm
Okay, wie krieg ich den jetzt komplett
Kann ich dem jetzt sagen
Ähm
With
H-Screen
Okay, wie krieg ich den Scheiß jetzt breit
Ich mein
Das funzt aus Gründen
Die sich mir nicht erschließen
Nicht wirklich
Also ich kann sagen
Ich will volle Breite
Aber wenn ich volle Breite hab, dann funktioniert das mit Margin zusammen nicht
Und ich hab
Eine Sache hab ich noch nicht
Gecheckt
Wie krieg ich
Mit
Der vollen Breite
Jetzt noch links und rechts
Ähm
Ne Margin hin
Guck, das geht nur links
Und rechts macht er das nicht
Wie krieg ich jetzt links und rechts
Ne Margin hin
Was Margin right
Null
Und dann
Du meinst ohne
Ohne die
Ohne die volle Breite
Ne
Na wenn ichs Relativ mach
Das ist ja Default
Dann hängts da oben
Das will ich ja nicht
Ich will ja schon dass es standardmäßig unten ist
Wie wäre es mit nem Padding und dann einem Child Diff
Das nicht die volle Breite bekommt
Ähm
Wenn ich das wüsste wieder
Warte mal
Ich probier das mal kurz mit Inline Styles
Um mal zu gucken ob ich da das
Style
Background
White
Position
Ups
So
So, wie sage ich dem jetzt, dass ich links und rechts einen Abstand haben will?
W, full, verstehe ich.
Ja, dann ist es 100%.
Wits, 100, CSS, Wits, 100%, but margin, left, right.
Aha, ja, excellent.
Hier erklären sie einem, wie es funktioniert.
And not with margin, okay.
Ja, ist ja gut zu wissen, aber...
Ach, ich glaube, ich weiß, was ich sage.
Ich muss sagen, left 2 und right 2 oder so.
Ah, das geht?
Left, hä?
Ach, please, so schwer kann das doch nicht sein.
CSS, KS.
Was ist das hier jetzt überhaupt?
Warum hängt denn das hier so rum?
Ich bin da zu noob.
Warum hängt denn das jetzt da in der Ecke?
Aber weil ich left...
Ich kacke, ich habe left.
Das geht nicht zusammen.
Margin, Auto.
Boah.
Wie kriege ich einen Footer, der links und rechts Platz hat und unten an der Seite hängt?
Entferne W, full, ja.
Und dann?
Hatte ich das nicht eben schon mal?
Das hatte ich doch ganz am Anfang schon mal.
Ach, nee, da hatte ich left und right nicht drin.
Excellent.
Alles klar.
Okay, so ist das schick.
Sehr nice, sehr, sehr nice.
So ist das, so ist das gut.
So mag ich das.
Okay, so.
Und, ja, gut.
Was soll ich da jetzt reinmachen?
Copyright, Copyright muss da unbedingt rein, immer.
Icon.
Immer Copyright, was sonst?
Äh, Material Design Icons.
Was haben die für ein...
Alles mal weg hier.
Gibt es da Copyright-Symbol?
Copyright.
Auf Seite.
Come on, such was.
Ja, Copyright, perfekt.
Brauchen wir da MDI.
Copyright.
Ich habe doch jetzt das Add-on.
Bye.
Wobblords.
Boah, exquisite Footer.
Footer ist am Start.
Ist das nicht...
Beautifully done.
Nicht bye.
Bye.
Excellent.
Ich bin begeistert, Leute.
So, und jetzt noch, und jetzt noch.
Align.
Center.
Dazu, dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Und, und wir brauchen das passende Emote.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich es habe.
Ich benutze das, ich benutze das so selten.
Unglaublich.
Jetzt Design.
Ein Chat.
Nee, nee, irgendwann ist es auch mal gut.
So, ich bin...
Guck mal, wie responsive das Ganze auch schon wieder ist.
Can't wait.
So, und jetzt ist die Frage, wie groß ist die Seite jetzt, wenn ich die...
Bild.
3,1.
Ach so.
Das ist wegen den Icons.
Die Icons sind zu, zu massive fett.
Die Fonts sind zu fett.
Die Fonts alleine sind ja schon...
3 MB oder so.
Der Rest ist...
Alter, sind die Fonts fett.
Warum, warum sind die Fonts so dicke?
Kann der nicht einfach nur die Fonts reinmachen, die, die ich brauche?
Äh, das kann sein, dass das rumspackt, wenn der Content länger wird.
Das stimmt.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Eine Runde mehr Lorem Ipsum.
Ja.
Das sieht kacke aus.
Wait a minute.
Ist absolut nicht immer unten am Bildschirmrand.
Ach nee, das ist fixed oder so, ne?
Ah, yes.
So ist besser.
Sticky.
So, jetzt ist natürlich die große Preis...
Cancel.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Ich glaube, ich muss das alles nochmal...
Das war jetzt nicht so, dass ich Big Bang hatte.
Ich müsste das hier alles in irgendeine Flexbox oder so stecken.
Weil jetzt floated das immer da oben drüber, was natürlich auch ziemlicher Sack ist, ne?
Aber da bin ich, da bin ich zu lowbrain für.
Da haben wir jetzt was für auszudecken.
Aber Sticky?
Macht Sticky was?
Ändert überhaupt nichts.
Was haben wir noch?
Static gibt's auch noch.
Oh.
Okay.
Und was passiert, wenn es jetzt weniger drinsteht?
Ja, geil.
Also, das ist ja...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das soll schon unten sein.
Sticky und dann was?
Bottom?
Ah, nee, haben wir ja schon.
Nee.
Da bin ich, da bin ich zu noobig für.
Aber es ist mir jetzt auch wurscht.
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht machen.
Wahrscheinlich normalerweise so nicht machen.
Weil ich glaube, viel sinnvoller wäre es, man würde das hier, wobei ich kann es ja mal ausprobieren.
Der Ausgernfuchs kennt sich aus mit sowas, das weiß ich.
Der hat da, der hat da Ahnung.
Da könnte man nämlich wirklich noch eine Flexbox drum machen.
Also quasi, dass wir jetzt sagen, ja und das da, das da ist der Titel.
Machen wir das mal so.
Dass wir jetzt hier irgendwie noch ein Diff drum machen.
So.
Und den Fixed machen wir mal raus.
Können wir jetzt hier noch Margin 2, nee, Margin ummachen.
Genau.
So.
Und jetzt sagen wir dem hier Class Flex.
Dann sieht es natürlich nicht richtig aus.
Ähm.
Jetzt muss man sagen Column, nee, Flex Poll.
So.
Und jetzt muss ich dem irgendwie sagen, dass der das letzte Element,
nach unten pushen soll.
Da habe ich aber keine Ahnung, wie ich das machen soll.
Was ist der Content Fill und der Parent is Min, was?
Last Child, ja.
Fill.
Was Justify Content Space Between.
Du meinst hier?
Space.
Space Between Tailwind.
Between.
What the fuck.
Justify.
Justify Content.
Wie macht man das?
Mit Tailwind?
Achso.
Ja.
Haben wir schon.
Und jetzt?
Ähm.
Kompletten Scree- Ah, Exquisite.
Ah, Moment.
Ja gut, jetzt macht er das andere natürlich.
Und nun?
Ja, ich habe da keine Ahnung von, Alter.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich mache.
Eigentlich ist das gar nicht mal schlecht jetzt.
Ich meine, guck mal, wenn ich jetzt hier den.
Doch, doch, das ist.
Das passt doch eigentlich.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht mal so übel.
Was, der Content Container muss nochmal in den Diff?
Äh.
Hier nochmal drumherum?
Richtiger Fronten Champ.
Oh.
Äh.
Ah, stimmt.
Weil es zwei Sachen sind, ne?
Ne.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Die sind doch alle hier drinnen.
Warum muss ich da nochmal einen Diff drumherum machen?
Was ist der Sinn?
Was ist der Sinn von diesem Diff?
So, und das muss ich jetzt
allein in den Top.
Wie auch immer ich das mache.
Das ist mir zu...
zu hoch. Ich fand das vorher aber
gar nicht so schlecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist eigentlich gut so
gewesen.
Das ist durchaus in Ordnung so.
Okay, aber jetzt...
Genau, was...
Gibt es noch irgendwas, was wir da jetzt mal mit Tailwind
ausprobieren könnten?
Also wir haben einen Footer gebastelt,
einen Button,
eine Karte, eine Navigations...
Chat. Ich baue da jetzt kein Chat.
Irgendein Formular oder so.
Das machen wir nochmal.
Wir machen noch irgendein Formular.
Zum Ausprobieren. Ne, die Animation bin ich zu
lowbrain dafür.
Wir machen den Content weg
und machen dann ein Formular draus.
Also
sprich...
Da ergibt das nämlich auch Sinn.
Mit dem
Save und Cancel hier unten.
Form.
Alter, ich weiß
aus dem Kopf doch am besten will nicht. Wie mache ich denn das denn jetzt?
Äh, Form.
Und dann was? Input?
Input. Einfach nur Text.
Oh, sieht das schlecht aus.
Ja.
Wenn du mehrere Cards hast,
dann kopiere ich die einfach.
Oder ich mache eine View Component draus.
Okay.
Ähm, wie Style... Okay.
Tailwind Form.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt was
Schönes für...
Wait a minute.
Was ist das?
Äh, also.
Ich habe keinen Plan davon.
Aber die Form können wir erstmal weglassen.
Entschuldigung.
Also.
Da muss man doch eh nur drum herum machen, wenn man die im Browser eingebaute, ähm, äh, Submit-Geschichte verwenden will, oder?
Ansonsten für Styling ist das doch eigentlich egal.
Oder?
So.
Also, das sieht kacke aus.
Wir brauchen erstmal ein Label.
Äh, oh fuck.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Monka S.
Label.
Uaah.
Sieht so scheiße aus, Alter.
Ähm.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Okay.
Also.
Das hier ist jetzt, keine Ahnung.
Ihr braucht jetzt irgendeine sinnlose Sache, irgendwie.
Username.
Oh.
So, Username.
Äh, pfff.
Äh, was weiß ich?
Username.
Location.
Ist ja egal.
So, jetzt machen wir mal eine schicke.
Oh, irgendwie sowas.
Stimmt, das muss, das muss ein Label sein.
Das, wenn man das nämlich anklickt.
Nee, das, das sieht doof aus, wenn das auf der gleichen, ich will das nicht auf der gleichen
Zeile haben, das Label.
Ja, genau, einfach Passwort.
So.
Passwort.
Da können wir nämlich hier auch gleich sagen, Typ Passwort ist doch, glaub ich, ne?
Dann ist hier nämlich die Sache gedingst.
So.
Was, der Input muss in den Label rein?
Wirklich?
Nee, oder?
Das Label sagt, schreibt man doch normalerweise oben drüber.
Also, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Also, Label, weil da kann man das nämlich dann auch anklicken.
Vor.
Da, da musste dem Ding, musste man doch irgendwie eine ID geben, ne?
Null.
Äh, User.
Ging das so?
Genau, wenn ich jetzt da drauf klicke, dann geht's nämlich da rechts rein.
Max.
Exzellent.
So.
Ähm.
Okay.
Also, Class.
Block.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
So.
Ähm.
Also, Class.
Block.
Sehr schön.
Exquisite.
Kann ich das nicht komplett für die ganze Form machen?
Ne.
Das geht natürlich net.
Was passiert, wenn ich dem Input Block geb?
Nix.
Nix wirklich, oder?
Ne.
Oder?
Ist das ein Unterschied?
Ne.
So.
Username.
Okay.
Also, da muss jetzt ein bisschen margin bottom 2, dass ein bisschen Abstand ist.
So.
Das Input sieht natürlich ziemlich kacke aus.
Wie kommt das?
Wie konnte man nochmal sagen, dass der kein Autofill, CSS, Autofill, das ging, das ging,
dass man ja den Form, dass der das nicht macht.
Formfill?
Fill?
Form?
Ah, wie ging das nochmal?
Autocomplete.
Oh, dat gibt's nicht.
Dat gibt's nicht.
Da muss ich ihm sagen, Input.
Da muss ich einen eigenen Style machen.
Ähm.
Ne.
Ach so, einfach in der Form oben, oder was?
Okay, das ist ja easy.
Warte mal, wenn das einfach in die Form oben muss.
Easy.
Ja.
Hätte ich mal gleich gewusst, dass es sowas gibt.
So.
Zack, zack.
So, das Form sieht natürlich ziemlich beschissen aus, so.
Man sieht kein Cursor und nix.
Also, als erstes würde ich sagen, kriegt das mal Outline None.
Geht's auch gut?
Ja.
Geht's auch schon gleich besser aus.
So, ähm, dann muss das natürlich ein bisschen, die Höhe muss ein bisschen größer sein.
Wie so, okay, okay, okay, okay, vielleicht, vielleicht nicht, nicht ganz so groß.
8, ah 8 ist gut.
Dann machen wir jetzt irgendwie, äh, Font.
Ne, äh, Text.
sei es moment text xl war es dann ja dann braucht das ding noch irgendwie einen padding intern
sonst sieht es nämlich gar so beschissen aus aber player ist abgekackt ich ich lerne ich
lerne tailwind ich habe keinen platz immer von frontend sachen okay das sieht doch eigentlich
ganz brauchbar aus aber text was gibt es noch text xl lg so ist es okay ist okay aber padding
sieht kacke aus so ist besser 2 gibt es sowas wie padding y 4 oh das ist nice padding y dass
der quasi nur oben und unten macht oder so ja cool
und padding x2 hey das gefällt mir das ist gut so sehr schön so wie sieht eine gute form aus was
braucht man da was braucht man da sonst noch für icon user user ich brauche ich brauche ein bisschen
ins inspiration wir hatten doch eben so was bisschen inspiration so login form sowas da
facebook login page alter monka christ gg weg
doch ich brauche ein bisschen ein bisschen inspiration da jetzt login form machst du
irgendwann einen stream mit .net kram wir haben total viel .net zeug schon gemacht das ist doch
schick dass sowas bauen wir jetzt sowas bauen wir jetzt so was ähnliches also das ist heißt
schon mal oben nicht content sondern heißt login ich muss sagen das sieht standardmäßig schon gar
nicht mal so beschissen aus
das einzige problem ist dass man das hier nicht richtig erkennt weil das
weil das weiß auf auf grau ist das sieht kacke aus das heißt das ding kriegt
erstmal outline weg by the way das hier unten das kopieren wir dann wenn es
fertig ist also jetzt müssen wir erstmal das outline
outline habe ich schon weg gemacht border shadow das ist eine gute idee ja
das ist gut aber ich würde sagen die farbe machen wir trotzdem anders border
zwei border
border break
raum wird man was hat heute was hat unser hintergrund für eine farbe create 200 das
sieht kacke aus oder blau wie die buttons das ist eine gute idee der border wird blau wenn
man reinklickt oder ein lov blitzkrieg h1 dankeschön für den
Das ist Manjaro mit E3 WM.
Der Border, wenn man reinklickt,
Fokus, wie kriegt der den gleichen?
Die gleiche Farbe
wie die Buttons.
Ups, äh, nein.
Aber wisst ihr,
was wir machen können? Wir können BG
vielleicht.
Das sieht scheiße aus.
Oh, hab ich dich übersehen?
Hab ich dich übersehen?
Der Tringer, 5 Monate,
danke für den Zap. Ja, ich hab's echt nicht gesehen.
Ich war so sehr in mein Werk vertieft.
Dankeschön alle für die Zaps.
Sorry, falls ich irgendwas übersehen hab.
Ich war so
vertieft in mein künstlerisches
Schaffen hier.
Shiana oder China, ich weiß nicht.
China. China.
Dankeschön für den Zap.
Eher Shiana,
denke ich mal.
Du kannst in der
Tablet Confirm Primary Colors definieren.
Dann kannst du die Farben als BG Primary nutzen.
Ja,
könnte ich machen.
Aber wir machen das jetzt so, wir machen da gar keinen...
Ey, vielleicht schaffe ich es doch nochmal
irgendwann, dass man den Kram hier
gescheit eingerückt bekommt.
So, Border kommt weg.
Das war useless.
Und
wir brauchen jetzt,
wenn das Ding Fokus hat,
BG Blue. Äh, nicht BG Blue.
Ähm, Border
Blue. Und dann?
Border
Blue.
Weil?
Ey, das ist doch cool.
Das ist doch Poggas, oder?
Wir bräuchten so eine standard inaktive Farbe.
Vielleicht einfach nur Border 1?
Border 2.
Wolltest du dir die Tage mal View anschauen?
Hast du dich letztens erzählt, du hast schon irgendwie
was mit View und irgendwie
Bulma CSS gemacht, oder verwechsel ich das jetzt?
Was habe ich denn hier nochmal als Hintergrund
genommen? 100?
Was hat denn das Ding hier für einen Hintergrund?
Dieser Blog?
Login?
100.
Ja passt doch.
Das ist cool.
Guck mal, das gefällt mir richtig gut, dass man da reinklicken kann, Poggas.
Excellent Form.
So, vielleicht machen wir den Username noch ein bisschen größer.
Soll ich irgendwie sagen Text?
Ja.
Oh, dann machen wir Login auch noch ein bisschen fetter.
Oh.
Ne, das sieht schon wieder zu fett aus, oder?
So, so ist schon ganz gut.
Aber wir könnten Login, Login, wisst ihr was wir machen?
Login.
Ja offsets machen.
Wir machen, Text.
Ich glaube das ist sowas, was man echt nur lernt, wenn Man es benutzt äh.
Sonst, bist du da echt am...
Abkacken.
Username mit Doppelpunkt oder ohne Doppelpunkt?
Das ist doch jetzt auch ein ganz nettes Form schon, so vielmehr braucht man jetzt noch
gar net.
Also sprich, jetzt kopieren wir das jetzt.
Und sagen nicht Username, sondern Passwort.
Wir machen noch Icons, wir machen auch nochmal Icon.
noch icons wir machen noch icons leute hat den top 2 jetzt müssen wir noch hier dass das type
passwort ist kann man noch ein icon oder wo machen wir dann schönes eignen wo ist in so
einer form immer ein icon hier vorne oder wo sind da icons zeigt man ja hier innen drin guck mal so
so was da so was da ist doch schick wir machen das wir machen das username icon machen wir da
innen rein wie kriegt man da innen reinen icon low brain jepp kock dass der placeholder dass
placeholder placeholder kann man auch noch machen account ist es glaube ich placeholder können wir
auch noch machen dass tatsächlich eine ganz gute idee aber placeholder in den plates holt das das
was da in reichert ich will jetzt eigene ist das der placeholder nee ich glaube dass da vorne
Vorne ist nicht der Placeholder.
Ne, ne, das ist nicht der Placeholder.
Hier hinten ist der Text, da vorne ist das Icon in der Form.
So, ähm.
Aber wir können den Placeholder reinmachen.
Oh.
Gar nicht mal schlecht.
Gefällt mir eigentlich.
Dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö-dö.
Topics, fünf Monate, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellent, Subscription.
So, wie kriege ich dieses Icon da jetzt rein?
Okay, äh.
Wir fragen es der Gauferflow.
Form, Input, User, Icon.
W3-Schools, die haben übelst gesagt.
Ah, ja, Moment.
Ihh, das sieht ja.
Ja, das kann ich auch.
Das kann ich auch, dass da so ein hässliches Ding davor ist.
Background?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja.
Sowas.
Wie geht das?
Input.
Das Styling vom Input wegmachen, dann Diff drum und das wie einen Input stylen.
Stimmt.
Eigentlich total einfach, ja.
So, das haben die hier wahrscheinlich auch so gemacht.
Ah, nee, die haben es mit absolut da reingeschoben, aber das suckt ziemlich.
Okay, okay, also sprich.
Machen wir das mal da hoch.
Also sprich, quasi ein Diff drum.
Machen wir das Label.
Muss das Label auch in das Diff rein?
Ja, wahrscheinlich funktioniert es sonst nicht, ne.
Weil ansonsten könnte ich das Label ja rauslassen.
Nee, funktioniert trotzdem noch.
So, und jetzt?
Und jetzt muss ich den...
Okay, also das heißt, ich mache jetzt mal das Styling da komplett.
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt?
Glas?
Okay.
Shadow gibt es schon mal.
Uäh!
Nee, nee, nee, das ist Müll.
Das ist doch kacke.
Nee.
Das muss, da muss es einen besseren Weg für geben.
Wie haben die das gemacht?
Glas, Input Field.
Haben die vielleicht auch funktionierende Sachen?
Ob man anklicken kann?
Field, Center.
Okay, die machen es genauso.
Die machen es genauso.
Die machen es, die machen es genauso.
Okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Die machen es echt so.
Dann.
Okay.
Also sprich, das heißt wir sagen, Background White.
Genau.
So, das Styling hier kommt komplett weg.
Okay, okay, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns der Sache.
Also, Input.
Bloß noch Outline auf None.
Es sieht doch schon fast gut aus.
Schon fast richtig, fast, fast richtig.
Diff.
Okay.
Die Breite sollte man vielleicht nochmal irgendwie.
Ich meine, 32 oder so.
Uäh, was ist das?
Ach so, das muss da reinpassen.
40.
Okay, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Wobei, wir können doch, können wir doch nicht sagen, Width.
Wir können doch sagen, der wird irgendwie so breit.
Und dann machen wir die Breite davon einfach voll.
Ne, funktioniert schon mal nicht.
Und das muss ich noch absolut machen, ha?
Glas.
Absolut.
Oh.
Ah, ne, ich hab schon mal ne.
Klasse.
So.
Ja.
Uäh.
Jetzt muss ich das aber noch ein bisschen verschieben.
Ähm.
Margin left 10 oder so.
Ja.
Geht doch.
Das sieht doch jetzt ganz brauchbar aus.
Ja.
Ich hab's auf absolut gemacht, weil ansonsten das Ding ne Zeile unten ist und ich keine Ahnung hab, was ich dagegen machen kann.
So.
Aber so funktioniert's auf jeden Fall auch.
Hey, das ist nice.
Oder auch nicht.
Ne, Padding brauchen wir da.
Äh.
Wie geht?
Ja, so ist es okay.
Und jetzt einen vollen Rahmen, wenn das Fokus hat.
Ach stimmt.
Wie kriegen wir da jetzt.
Moment, wie kriegen wir da jetzt Fokus hin?
Wait a minute.
Wie kriegen wir da jetzt ein Fokus hin?
Kann ich das einfach auf dem Diff machen?
Border.
Ah, fuck. Ja.
Fuck.
Scheiße.
Wie krieg ich da jetzt ein Bor...
Ah.
Okay.
Jetzt, jetzt ist vorbei, Leute.
Jetzt ist, jetzt ist RIP.
Hahaha.
Ah, Moment.
Ich hab gar keinen Border angegeben.
Border 2.
Ach du Scheiße.
Wie krieg ich denn...
Active vielleicht?
Fuck.
Okay, das, das wird nicht so ohne weiteres funktionieren.
Das muss anders gemacht werden.
Das muss anders gemacht werden, Leute.
Das kann...
Das wird so nicht funktionieren.
Wie krieg ich das...
...gefokust, wenn ich da...
...drinne bin?
Du solltest, glaube ich, beim umschließen...
...den Diff einfach Position Relative machen.
Position Relative ist doch...
Aber wenn ich das Styling...
Ne, das bringt mir auch nichts.
Wenn ich das Styling auf das...
...auf das Input verschiebe...
...kommt ja nur ein Border...
...und das Icon nicht.
Ach du Scheiße.
Wie macht man denn sowas?
Ich meine, an sich sieht das jetzt ja schon ganz brauchbar aus.
Ne?
So, wir machen das so Diff.
Noch die Höhe irgendwie 10 oder so.
Öh.
Warte.
Was ist das?
Meine Güte.
Ey, ist das hässlich jetzt.
Okay, das ist mir zu...
Ne, also...
Jaja, Auskennen folgt, glaube ich dir.
Also, das, das ist sucked.
Das machen wir mal rückgängig wieder.
Das war, glaube ich, keine...
...keine gute Idee, was ich da gebastelt habe jetzt.
So.
Das war doch schon fast gut.
Das war doch schon fast, fast gut.
Guck mal, das ist fast gut.
Ich meine, wir könnten jetzt...
...wenn man jetzt ja irgendwie...
...dieses Ding da reinschieben könnte...
...so, dass der Text auf der...
...später anfängt.
Wobei, können wir doch, oder?
Können wir doch?
Wartet mal.
Das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht so schwer, oder?
Hör mal.
Placeholder.
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Dann sagen wir Padding.
Padding left.
Keine Ahnung.
Zehn oder so?
Ach, nee.
Ah, Moment.
Was mache ich denn da?
Lohnt mich.
Ähm.
Padding.
Ah, nein.
Kein...
Padding.
Äh.
Left.
Zehn.
Ja, das geht doch.
Und jetzt kann ich es da reinschieben.
Alles gut.
Passt doch.
Jetzt mache ich Position absolut bei dem Ding.
Ja.
Moment.
Oh, das ist so ätzend.
Das ist jetzt...
Ah.
Ja, ja.
POG, POG, POG.
Äh.
Label.
Nee, Moment.
Wie, wie konnte man...
Wow, wow.
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Alter.
Ah, nee.
Jetzt musste man noch sagen...
Äh, äh.
Text.
XL oder so.
Ja.
Wir nähern uns.
POG Champ.
Excel 2.
Ja.
Das sieht schon furchtbar aus.
Das sieht schon fast gut aus.
Fast.
Fast gut.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen Positionierungsfrage noch.
By the way, was geben wir dem Ding denn mal für einen Border, dass es nicht so kacke aussieht?
So, hä?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich mit Tailwind Transforms mache.
So.
Guck mal, das ist doch fast, fast schon gut.
So, dann machen wir das jetzt so.
Wenn du noch einen Input hinzufügst, dann rutscht das Icon.
Ja, gut.
Ich kann sie in ein eigenes Diff packen, oder?
Nö, da rutscht kein Icon.
Alles gut.
Funst.
Tailwind ist mehr oder weniger normales CSS, nur dass es halt normales CSS generiert aus
Tags, die man irgendwie...
Also, es hat schon vorgeneriertes CSS, was es dann applied mit den Klassen.
Also, im Prinzip ist das ganz normales CSS.
Man muss halt wissen, was hintenbei rauskommt.
So.
Dark Sea müssen wir noch machen.
Leute, ich muss aber auch gleich was essen.
So.
Also, das sieht schon mal kacke aus mit dem Icon hier.
Also, wir müssen ein Icon.
So, Textgröße.
Text.
Ray.
200.
Nee, kacke.
400.
500.
600.
400.
Boah.
So, und jetzt kriegt es noch Margin Left 2.
Left 1.
Leute, das sieht doch jetzt schon echt nett schlecht aus.
So.
Das sähe ich jetzt richtig gut aus.
Das sieht doch jetzt ECHTёт schlecht aus, oder?
Pudding Left 7?
Das gefällt mir.
Das ist top, oder?
Also, da kann man doch nichts sagen.
Das ist doch echt, das ist doch echt gut so.
Da würde ich mich anmelden.
Nice.
Das kann man doch das echt so lassen.
Also, das sieht doch wirklich nach ordentlichen Logi-Ding aus.
So.
Anmeldung ist raus.
Ja.
Würde ich auch sagen.
Ich meine, was, was will man da noch mehr haben, großartig, nä?
Was sagt der aus KenFuchs? Der kennt sich aus, das weiß der ist CSS Pro. Passwort,
ja das können wir jetzt noch machen. Äh. Rausklicken kann man nicht, oder?
Ah, das ist doch okay so. Ich finde das okay. Machen wir noch eins drunter. Du würdest noch ein
bisschen Padding oben und unten machen. Äh. Quasi. Ja, stimmt. Also quasi anstatt.
Padding X und Padding Left beißt sich. Ja, ja, okay. Also Padding Right auch nochmal. Okay,
ja. Ih! Was ist das? Na gut, auf der anderen Seite, wie soll es denn auch sonst sein, ne?
Ja, wie soll es denn auch sonst sein?
Ich meine das Icon muss ja davor sein. Okay. Oh, jetzt wollen wir mal Padding Y4 oder sowas.
Ja. Oh. Ey. Jetzt stimmt es ja von der Höhe nicht mehr. Sackt jetzt. Dann muss ich das
noch ein bisschen größer machen. Das sieht jetzt aber kacke aus. Vorher war besser. Äh,
nein, nein. Ich lasse das so wie es vorher war. Lass das jetzt so. Aber wenn man da auf das Icon,
was kann ich denn machen, dass er das fokussiert?
Was kann ich denn machen, dass er das fokussiert? Was kann ich denn machen, dass er das fokussiert?
wenn ich auf das icon klicke ich könnte das hier zum ich könnte das hier als
label machen das wird quasi das da
massive braucht da keine überschrift was jetzt natürlich noch geiler wenn es
wenn es fokussiert ist dass das auch blau wird da hört es dann aber schon
wieder auf weil da müssen wir in die java script geschichte machen
sonst sonst wird das nix perfekt so okay was jetzt keck wait wo ist das
problem immer diffs drum wenn man diffs drum macht dann dann fix das alles easy
was ist mit fokus ja keine ahnung was man mit fokus machen
sollen
so passwort was ist ein gutes icon für passwort mdi key oder sowas hieß das
da okay punkt placeholder und hier placeholder so ist es schick das gefällt
mir richtig gut jetzt da könnte ich hier noch ein bisschen mehr padding machen
padding left mama 8 dann passt es nicht so dran
das ist richtig gut das ist richtig gut das ist richtig gut das ist richtig gut
login form so bleibt das jetzt ein total passwort ja ja da ist da würde ich
mich anmelden leute lockt lockt kennt man glaube ich eh an ein
bein im fokus auf den input kannst du das eigen fermi das habe ich mir auch
schon überlegt aber ich weiß nicht wie ich das machen kann ohne java script
weil ich weiß nicht ob das erkennt das ist es ist er kennt das label das dass
active ist
oder fokus fokus hat erkennt das ding nicht ob was einen button hinter passwort dass man auch
sieht man das passwort richtig geschrieben hat ja das ist jetzt das mit safe und login das ist
jetzt ja nur optik ja das mumu fahren hat man aber eben auch schon das geht mit group fokus
was ist gut fokus fokus gruppe alles klar fokus gruppe was für ein ding fokus within
input group jetzt wird es jetzt wird es wird exzellent group fokus
ja moment aber nur wenn es innen drin ist oder ich würde das label
nicht
so funktioniert das nicht oder vielleicht auf das diff ja wenn das innen drin ist dann
funktioniert das aber ich kann ja wohl den das kaum in das input rein machen oder das
funktioniert in dem fall glauben nicht aber dass der fahrt ja kein
fokus wenn ich hier reinklicken hier probiere mal aus grupo das gruppe fokus was wird
aus gruppe das gruppe fokus kannst du noch ein vorlese button ja das 않고
lese ja das könnte man das könnte man schon machen ja aber das will ich jetzt
Fokus bieten
nicht design zumal die seite nur zum üben ist in den input input aber ich will noch das label
fern nicht den input Intro
im input könnte ich mir vorstellen dass so einохtern Edinburgh Studies ist das input vorlesen in der opinion freund hometown asleep spiele moskow im input könnte mãn schweizpulver wir sind da das 이
könnte ich mir vorstellen dass es sogar funktioniert oder auch nicht da bin ich
da bin ich zu low brain für als das checken was ist das focus within css aha
glas fokus ok ok so müsste man das doch irgendwie gebacken bekommen text text
yellow okay dass das vier vererben funktioniert schon mal weil ich hier
den text nicht gesetzt habe aber ich will dass das andere blau text
ok dann machen wir das so text ist gray wenn das fokus ist wird das blau 500
blue was haben wir da blue 100 ok das funktioniert
jetzt muss ich hier nur noch den text weg machen ok und hier über schreiben
wir jetzt die text mit carl black
excellent excellent jetzt wird's blau äußerst schick ist das
schick kann man irgendwie das spacing von dem cursor ich weiß jetzt wird
es echt jetzt wird es echt eklig das spacing zwischen placeholder und cursor
ändern kann man den placeholder irgendwie verschieben oder so oder kann man den placeholder
weg machen sobald man reinklickt naja so aber das ist das das ist sehr schick das
gefällt mir das ist exquisite da könnten wir jetzt da könnten wir jetzt eine view
komponente draus extrahieren aber das machen wir jetzt nicht weil ich habe übelst hunger
lockt ja nice also das muss ich sagen das gefällt mir jetzt das hat was haben
wir ein bisschen tailwind gelernt leute da würde ich mich einloggen kekw 123456
bestes passwort beim login aber moment hier hier kannst den padding erhöhen
dann schiebt sich noch weiter doch das gefällt mir exzellent so mag ich das so
mag ich das so mag ich das so mag ich das so mag ich das so mag ich das so mag ich das
so mag ich das so mag ich das so mag ich das so mag ich das so mag ich das so mag ich das
Rounded
MD.
Oh, so ist es noch besser.
So ist es nice.
So ist es noch besser, oder? Jawohl.
Exquisite. Ich bin begeistert, Leute.
Esst auch Captchas.
Ja, das gefällt mir richtig gut jetzt.
Sehr, sehr gut.
Excellent, excellent.
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendjemanden hosten kann.
Aber ich muss erstens mal übelst dringend
pinkeln.
Und
was essen.
Leute, es war schön, dass ihr dabei wart
heute. Bisschen viel
rumprobiert, aber ich meine, so lernt man auch was.
Aber ich glaube, es kann sich sehen lassen
für das, dass ich absolut scheiße bin.
Also richtig
scheiße, was Frontend-Design
angeht.
Und dass ich von Tailwind keine Ahnung habe.
Ich glaube, das kann man so lassen.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Macht's gut. Wir sehen uns.
Michael Fuftspilian.
Ich kann leider nichts dran ändern, aber
wir müssen noch sein Custom-Emo
machen.
Alles klar, macht's gut. Bis dann.
See you.